welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford School of
Medicine my guest today is Dr Lisa
Feldman Barrett Dr Lisa Feldman Barrett
is a distinguished professor of
psychology at Northeastern University
she also holds appointments at Harvard
Medical School and Massachusetts General
Hospital where she is the chief
scientific officer of the center of law
brain and behavior Dr Barett is
considered one of the top World experts
in the study of emotions and her
laboratory has studied emotions using
approaches both from the fields of
Psychology and Neuroscience indeed today
you will learn about the neural circuits
and the psychological underpinnings of
what we call emotions you will learn
what emotions truly are and how to
interpret different emotional states you
also learn how emotions relate to things
like motivation Consciousness and affect
affect is a term that refers to a more
General State of brain and body that
increases or decreases the probability
that you will experience certain
emotions during today's discussion Dr
Feldman Barrett also teaches us how to
regulate our emotions effectively as
well as how to better interpret the
emotional states of others you'll also
learn about the powerful relationship
that exists between our emotional states
and the movement of our body in fact
much of today's discussion is both
practical and will be highly informative
in terms of the mechanisms underlying
emotions and it is likely to also be
surprising to you in a number of ways it
certainly was surprising to me I've been
a close follower of Dr Feldman Barrett's
work over many years now and have always
found it to be tremendously informative
and when I say her work I mean both her
academic published papers as well as her
public lectures that she's given and her
two fabulous books on emotions in the
brain the first one entitled how
emotions are made and the second book
which includes information about
emotions but extends beyond that
entitled s and a half lessons about the
brain as you'll see from today's
discussion Dr Feldman Barrett is not
only extremely informed about the
neuroscience and psychology of emotion
she's also fabulously good at teaching
us that information in clear terms and
in actionable ways you'll also notice
several times she pushes back on my
questions in some cases even telling me
that my questions are ill posed and I
have to tell you that I was absolutely
delighted that she did that because
you'll see that every time she did that
it was with the clear purpose of putting
more specificity on the question and
thereby more specificity and Clarity on
the answer which of course she delivers
by the end of today's discussion you
will have both a broad and a deep
understanding of what emotions are and
their origins in our brain and body you
will also have many practical tools with
which to better understand and navigate
emotional states and moreover you'll
have many practical Tools in order to
increase your levels of motivation and
better understand your various States of
Consciousness before we begin I'd like
to emphasize that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford it is however part of
my desire and effort to bring zero cost
to Consumer information about science
and science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is eight sleep
eight sleep makes Smart mattress covers
with cooling Heating and sleep tracking
capacity I've spoken many times before
on this podcast about the fact that
sleep is the foundation of mental health
physical health and performance one of
the key things to getting a great
night's sleep is to control the
temperature of your sleeping environment
and that's because in order to fall and
stay deeply asleep your body temperature
has to drop by 1 to 3° and in order to
wake up in the morning feeling refreshed
your body temperature actually has to
increase by 1 to 3° with eight sleep
it's very easy to control the
temperature of your sleeping environment
it's a mattress cover that allows you to
control the temperature of your sleeping
environment at the beginning middle and
end of your night and in doing so allow
you to fall and stay stay deeply asleep
throughout the night and wake up feeling
extremely refreshed I started sleeping
on an eight- sleep mattress cover well
over 2 years ago and it has greatly
improve the quality of my sleep if you'd
like to try eight sleep you can go to
8sleep.com
huberman to save up to $150 off their
pod 3 cover eight sleep currently ships
in the USA Canada UK select countries in
the EU and Australia again that's
8sleep.com
huberman today's episode is also brought
To Us by levels levels is a program that
lets you see how different foods and
behaviors affect your health by giving
you real-time feedback using a
continuous glucose monitor one of the
most important factors impacting your
immediate and long-term health is the
way that your body manages its blood
glucose or sometimes referred to as
blood sugar levels to maintain energy
and focus throughout the day you want to
keep your blood glucose steady without
big spikes or dips using levels you can
monitor how different types of foods and
different food combinations as well as
food timing and things like exercise
combined to impact your blood glucose
levels I started using levels a little
over a year ago and it gave me a lot of
insight into how specific Foods were
spiking my blood sugar and then leaving
me feeling tired for several hours
afterwards as well as how the spacing of
exercise and my meals was impacting my
overall energy and in doing so it really
allowed me to optimize how I eat what I
eat when I exercise and so on such that
my blood glucose levels and energy
levels are stable throughout the day if
you're interested in learning more about
levels and trying a continuous UC Co
monitor yourself go to levels. l/
huberman right now levels is offering an
additional two free months of membership
again that's levels. linkli nkh huberman
to get two free months of membership and
now for my discussion with Dr Lisa
Feldman Barrett Dr Lisa Feldman Barrett
welcome wow it's my pleasure to be here
I've wanted to talk to you for a very
long
time I'd like to talk about emotions I
think every everyone has a sense somehow
of what an emotion is feeling happy
feeling sad
feeling excited
feeling uh Curious perhaps is even an
emotion I don't know you'll tell us what
are the core components what are the
sort of
macronutrients of a of an emotion uh
because I know there's a debate about
whether or not we should be talking
about emotions versus States but what is
an
emotion we all are familiar with what
one feels like to us but from a
scientific perspective how do you define
an emotion well SCI this is a scientist
debate about this um nobody in the last
150 years has ever been able to agree on
what an emotion is um and I think from
my perspective the interesting but
tricky bit is that anytime you want to
talk about what the basic building
blocks are of emotion none of those
basic building blocks are specific to
emotion so for example there are a group
of scientists who will tell you well an
emotion is a coordinated response where
you have a change in um some physical
state a change in the brain a change in
the physical state um which um leads you
to make a particular facial expression
so you've got physiological changes in
the body changes in the brain changes in
the face or in motor movements
okay but that describes basically every
moment of your life um your face is
always moving in some way if it wasn't
you would look like an avatar basically
so we're we're constantly engaged in in
movements and those movements have to be
coordinated with the physiological
changes in the body because whether
we're whether we're in a state that we
would conventionally call emotion or not
because the physiology is supporting
those it's supporting the you know the
glut glucose and the oxygen and all the
things that you need to make uh
movements of your body and of course all
these movements are being coordinated by
your brain so of course there's a
coordinated set of um features that
doesn't really describe how emotions are
distinct from any other experience that
you have but the the claim was for a
really long time that there would be
diagnostic patterns okay so when
something triggered fear
you would have an increase in heart rate
and you would have um a propensity to
run away or to freeze or um not just to
fall asleep although that is something
animals do when they are faced with a
predator but that's not part of the
western stereotype for fear so that
wasn't what scientists were looking for
and um and also that you would make a a
particular facial expression which was
presumed to be the universal expression
of fear where you widen your eyes and
you get gasp
like um that facial set of facial
movements in other cultures like in
melanesian culture for example is um is
a symbol of threat where you are
threatening someone you are threatening
them with aggression basically is a war
face but in Western cultures that's the
the face that Western scientists
believed was the you know the the
distinctive part of that distinctive
pattern for fear and so the way that
scientists defined emotion for a long
time was these kind of um states where
you'd see this diagnostic Ensemble of
signals and that would mean that anytime
someone showed one of those signals they
may move their face in a particular way
or their heart increased at a particular
time you'd be able to diagnose them as
being in a state of fear as opposed to a
state of anger or sadness or whatever
the empirical evidence um just doesn't
bear that out and so it was kind of a
mystery the mystery is how is it that
you feel angry or sad or happy or you
know full of gratitude or awe how is it
that you experience these moments but
scientists can't find a single set of
physical
markers that correspond with each state
distinctively right that in a way that
you could tell them apart that's a that
was a really big puzzle for a really
long
time I have to ask you about this
perhaps myth perhaps truth about facial
expressions and
emotions because as you were explaining
the core components of
emotions I had to think back to to the
classic textbook images of the different
faces associated with fear with delight
with confusion on and on we we will get
to that and your opinions on that
scientifically informed opinions of
course but there is a bit of a myth that
the emotion system and the facial
expression system run in both directions
for
instance people will say if you smile
it's harder to feel sad or
anxious I can't say that's been my
experience but I very well could be
wrong so we know that when people's
emotional states change their facial
expressions often will change right if
you see someone crying on the street um
versus somebody smiling really big you
we can make some assumptions about what
might be going on at uh internally for
them but put simply is it true that
changing one's facial expression
can direct shifts in the brain and body
perhaps that change our emotional states
if you'll permit me what I would say is
that your question is ill
posed so first of all it presumes that
there's an emotion
system and that there's a facial
expression system now clearly there's a
system for moving facial muscles okay
but a movement is not the same as an
expression a movement is a movement an
expression is an interpretation of the
meaning of a movement not all movements
of the face are
expressions um and this is a you know a
problem it's a problem in science um in
it's often the case uh I think in my
experience in the science of emotion but
elsewhere to that scientists in their
efforts to make their work
um meaningful to people will try to
interpret their findings in in ways that
uh the average person would um find
interesting or the way that a physician
would find interesting or a teacher or
what have you to be able to use this
information but then they forget that
they're actually making an
interpretation and they start to refer
to their observations with the labels of
interpretation so facial movements are
facial movements people move their faces
and that those movements have meaning
but they're not always to express an
internal state in fact one might think
that they're very rarely to um Express
an internal state so I don't know that
there's a facial expression system
either so that's there is certainly like
I said um there there's circuitry for
moving a face but um but what those
movements mean um is highly variable and
so that would be my second point that
where I would say when you see someone
crying on the street you are not looking
only at their face you might be
aware um that you're focusing on their
face that might be the part of the
entire sensory Ensemble that you are
focusing your attention on but your
brain is taking in an entire ensemble of
signals as you know it's taking in not
just the you know movements of the face
that tears or whatever it's taking in
all of the the entire sensory array The
Sounds the smells what's going on inside
your own body your brain is being um
bombarded with signals from from all of
those sources and when it's making an
meaning out of any signal it's doing it
in an ensemble of signals so research
shows that baby's
cries aren't acoustically specific to
when they're tired or hungry or right um
the you can I can show you a video
without context and show you someone
crying and um you might make a judgment
you might think make the stereotypic
judgment in the west oh that person is
sad and then we pan out and really you
know it's a little girl whose dad just
came home from Iraq or something right
so brains are always interpreting faces
in context they're making guesses this
is something that I've talked about
quite a bit that we don't read movements
in people we don't read emotions in
facial Expressions we make inferences
about the emotional meaning of facial
movements and we do it in an ensemble of
other signals the the context uh as you
if you will and that's really what's
what's happening so um do I think that
um that there is feedback from the face
to the brain sure I mean there's
feedback from every muscle but there's
this constant conversation between the
brain and the body um the brain is
sending motor commands the body is you
know has sensory surfaces which are
sending signals back to the brain so if
the face is influencing the brain it's
doing so in a way that's not special it
it's doing it in a way that that works
for all other parts of your body too and
I
guess what I would say this kind of
long-winded answer
but over time your brain has
learned that certain patterns of signal
over
time um recur and so if you're smiling
if your brain is you know telling your
your facial muscles to move in a
particular way that looks like smiling
um it's happening in a larger Ensemble
of signals and then the brain is
predicting what's going to happen next
because it's learned over time
what happens next so probabilistically
so if you think about that as cause then
sure but it's not as it's not this
simplistic kind of idea that an emotion
is triggered um uh it
causes facial muscles to move in a
particular way and therefore if you just
pose your face in in those in that
particular Arrangement it that will
somehow feed back to the emotion system
and change that system because there are
no there is no emotion system in your
brain and the the causation just isn't
that it's not that simplistically
mechanistic that makes sense to me I I
uh frankly never bought the idea that
just smiling would make me feel happy um
especially if my internal state was not
one of Happiness like fighting the
internal state also um in the early
2000s I think it was there was a lot of
discussion about how positioning the
body in certain ways you know taking up
more space would allow people to feel
more powerful and they some of these
studies um and uh argued that there were
even hormonal shifts associated with um
taking up more space that were
associated with feelings of empowerment
and then when shrinking of oneself was
in associated with elevated cortisol
States and as I say all this I'm I I
want to be clear that um do not take a
simplistic view of the nervous system or
endocrine system and I I didn't um I
don't think that you were implying that
either so want to make sure that anyone
listening or watching isn't thinking
that uh for instance that cortisol is
bad cortisol is wonderful and essential
you just need it regulate properly or
that um the idea that the body and
emotional states are are inextricably
linked makes a ton of sense to me but
the idea that you could just you know
grab onto one of the nodes in the EM now
I have to be careful not say emotion
system um like position of the body like
being hunched over makes you depressed
no that never made sense to me taking up
more space makes you feel more uh
powerful that doesn't it it can't be
that way and yet we were told for about
a decade through especially through
popular press that this stuff was true
um and so what I love about your work is
that it includes a neuroanatomical a
psychological a Network perspective that
that there isn't one seat of emotions
and and so on um so if we could go a
little bit further into the facial
expression piece for a moment
sure I was taught in my Psychology and
Neuroscience textbooks because it was
right there in front of me that there
were some core categories of facial
expression that were Universal cross
cultures that conveyed something about
the internal state of the person that
the downward you know lips in the corner
and and some and maybe even a furrowing
of the brow was associated with negative
veent States like sadness perhaps even
depression that the opposite of upward
turn corners of the mouth and widening
of the eyes was delight and excitement
some of that feels pretty true to my
experience but how do you and other
serious scientists of emotions view that
somewhat classic literature now yeah so
I'll just say that my um
my journey here my scientific Journey
was not one of um attempting to
overturn um a Century's worth
of are we alled to swear
basically I mean it's just it's like
it's it's stereotyp it's basically
Western stereotypes enshrined as
scientific uh fact and that sounds like
a pretty harsh thing to say but I think
I pretty much stand by that at this
point
um but for me when I was a graduate
student When I Was An undergraduate in
uh in Psychology and in physiology and
in anthropology you know I also had read
that Darwin said that there were these
distinctive facial expressions that um
were coordinated with specific emotional
states specific states of the nervous
system this was Darwin's View and I
assumed it was correct
um until I started to try to use that
information um in the lab and everything
fell apart you know so when you show
someone in uh a laboratory like a
student or um somebody from the
community a face a disembodied face
where their the person's eyes are
widened in the face and they're gasping
like a stereotypic fear
expression most of the time they don't
know what it
is and so I would try to use these faces
and um as stimuli and experiments and
they W they weren't working the way that
they were supposed to work and there
were really going all the way back to
the beginning of psychology there were
always debates about whether or not this
was actually accurate and there's a
really interesting story about how
Darwin came to this idea um which I can
tell you about but it it's not because
he cared about emotion and he was
basically taking his own very Western
views about emotion to make some claims
about Evolution actually so um I have
more to say about that and
about why it's a problem to take
anything that anybody said even Darwin
from you know 150 or so years ago or
whatever it is and treat it like it's a
modern text you know he was writing at a
particular time for a particular purpose
um and that doesn't necessarily mean
that whatever he wrote is
true um but I'll just tell you what the
evidence
says um that there has been in
Psychology a debate really vicious
debate actually for probably 50 years
about the nature of facial expressions
and whether they are Universal and
whether there's this onetoone
correspondence between a particular face
and like a facial configuration in a
particular emotional state smiling in
happiness scowling in Anger wrinkling
your nose and disgust and so in
2016 I think the association for
psychological
science um tasked me and some other
senior
scientists uh with attempting to write a
white paper a consensus paper on what
the literature actually show so what
does the research actually show if you
read all the research you know can you
find a pattern there does it actually
reveal anything about whether or not
facial expressions are Universal
particularly for emotion um and the way
they do this they have a journal for
this purpose for taking a widely held
belief that is highly debated and
bringing together a panel of experts who
disagree with each other at the outset
and they have to work together to see if
they can come to consensus over
the
data and this is something that you know
people have tried in the past and I mean
they're really vicious people have been
vicious with each other over this
question so when we brought together a a
group of people so me several people
refused to serve senior scientists
refused to serve on this panel but out
of fear of losing their funding or
something um you know that's a whole
other conversation about
why SC certain scientists would not want
to engage W uh with um people who
disagree with them um that's an
interesting conversation to have but um
I don't think it's as simple actually as
just they their careerist or they they
care about you know their money or or
funding or whatever that would be an
easy answer but I don't actually think
that's what's going on but that's
another sort of but anyway so uh there
were five of us who got together um all
senior scientists all from different
fields some of us hadn't met each other
before we all knew of each other of
course and we met over Zoom for two and
a half years this is preco because
people were all over the world right and
we we read over a thousand papers so so
I was the only one in this group of the
five of us who my starting hypothesis
was that facial movements are meaningful
but they're not there's no one-o-one
correspondence between a particular
facial configuration like a
scowl and anger not not just that it
would vary across cultures but that it
varies AC for you across situations I
mean do you scowl every time you're
angry I don't scowl every time I'm angry
in fact and I also scowl at times when
I'm not angry
so and there are scientific reasons to
think that that the that a the
collection of facial expressions that
people make when they're angry or when
they're sad or whatever would be highly
variable so that was my starting
position and then the there were varying
four guys so there was I just refer to
them as the guys because it was me and
four guys and the guys they all to some
extent thought that facial expressions
were Universal but they had differing
reasons and all for for for
hypothesizing that and they
also had different commitments degrees
of commitment to
that position but we right off the bat
sort of agreed that we it didn't matter
who was right that was just not relevant
the only thing that mattered was that we
could come to the consensus over the
data and if we couldn't we had to really
pinpoint why like so what would be the
critical experiments that would have to
be done in order for us to come to
consensus over the data and we also
agreed that um we had all kinds of
contingency set up so you know you've
got five senior people who are all
running big labs and they're investing
you know upwards of three years working
on a paper so if we can't come to
consensus what are we going to do are we
going to write one paper and sort of
write about the process or are we going
to write separate papers or you know but
we we had all these contingencies laid
out but the key here I think is that we
agreed that we were not going to be
adversarial about it because it didn't
matter who was right and in fact if
somebody had to admit they were wrong
and someone was going to have to admit
they were wrong I mean it turns out all
of us were wrong about something but it
we were going to be like supportive of
each other and and really encourage each
other um because you know being wrong is
no one likes to be wrong but for
scientists to admit they're wrong is
hard and it's something that we should
encourage each other to do I think more
and and more
publicly and I think the people who do
that are really Brave and so that was my
position and they all agreed and the
long story short here is
that two and a half years a thousand
papers later we all very reasonably came
to consensus that there was no evidence
for facial expressions of emotion being
Universal and that instead what is what
there's clear evidence of is um that
facial expressions the way that people
move their faces in in in moments of
expression is highly variable
meaning sometimes in Anger you scowl
meta analyses so statistical summaries
of many many many studies even in the
west show that people
scowl about 35% of the time when they're
angry which is more than chance so it
get you a good publication in you know
the proceedings of the National
Academy but that means 65 % of the
time people are moving their faces in
other meaningful ways that's not
scowling so if you actually used a
scowl um or even you know a scowl in
blood pressure or you know just maybe
not one signal but like a couple signals
but you would be wrong more than half
the time you would miss more than half
the cases and even more
importantly I think that that's the
reliability question so there's low
reliability for um the the
correspondence between a scowl and anger
it's above chance so scowling is one
expression of anger but it's certainly
not the dominant one and there is no
dominant one it's just highly variable
depending on the situation that you're
in so sometimes when I'm angry I sit
quietly and plot the demise of my enemy
you know sometimes I smile in Anger
Sometimes I Cry in Anger it really
depends on the
situation um but more importantly half
of the scowls that people make are not
related to
anger that means that the
specificity is
again higher than
chance but not that much higher than
chance so if you see someone
scowling the chances are that they might
not be angry they might be concentrating
really hard or they might have gas I
mean there are a lot of reasons why
people make a SC owl um and we found
this for every emotion category that had
ever been studied and I want you to
notice what I just did there I'm not I'm
no longer referring to an emotion as if
it's an entity or a thing so anger isn't
one thing it's a category of things a
grouping of things and if I'm not
mistaken it includes verbs right that
like anger as a set of verb actions in
the in the brain and body yes it's a
process it's not an event process
exactly it's not a noun it's a verb and
it's a and it's a process but the point
is that um it's it's a highly variable
grouping of
instances if you're if you are talking
about all instances of anger all
instances of anger that you have ever
experienced or witnessed um is a highly
variable grouping of instances That Vary
that they that doesn't mean they're
random but what the body does in Anger
depends on what the physical movements
will be in anger and that depends on the
situation that you're in and what your
goal is and um and there are ways to
talk about that in Neuroscience terms
which are a little more precise but the
important thing to understand here I
think is that we're only talking about
Western cultures now the minute that you
go outside of the West to or even to the
east I mean so you know there are other
cultures you know that have been studied
um like uh China and cultures in China
in Japan in Korea they they all have
access to knowledge about Western
cultural practices a norm so what
happens when you go to you know to
remote cultures which um have much less
access so they it's not like they have
no access because we live in a
globalized world so even hunter
gatherers in Tanzania the hza have
access to Western practices and Norms
but much less much less and we did do
that and and um and all bets are off
there I mean most of the time they don't
even they don't even understand or
experience facial movements as having
anything to do with emotion so if they
saw an emoji of a smiley face would they
just assume it was a couple they might
think it's a face there because as we
both know there's some fairly hardwired
brain circuitry for the the two eyes and
a and a line beneath it and something in
the middle that's pseudo nose that
organization of just spatial features
cues up face for both for most prates
it's really interesting that you say
that because yes of course that's true
but it's not there at Birth what's there
at Birth is a preference for that
configuration right so it's it's like
there's some and we could talk about why
that's there it's actually very
controversial but um but what babies
what newborns Orient to they Orient to
that or they Orient to that
configuration but it doesn't have to be
a face and then very quickly they start
learning faces because they're exposed
to fa I mean really the first three
months of life is almost like a massive
continuous tutorial on what faces are
because they're you know being fed and
and everyone's in your face saw a baby
last night and you see the baby friends
of have a unbelievably cute baby with
the big cheeks and you want and there's
this desire to see the baby smile right
so you do the things that and if that
the baby shows some sort of facial
expression that makes it seem like it's
a little bit um like resist in what
you're doing you you stop doing it you
change up your strategy and then when
baby cracks a smile like now I'm going
to assume that the baby may or may not
have been happy inside um that little
baby head um but when they do there's a
reciprocity then we smile there's a
template that that's very robust right
but I want you to notice though that so
first of all I'm not saying that um that
recognizing faces a face as a face is
not hardwired it is but it's hardwired
by not by genes alone right and in fact
there's a really wonderful book called
not by genes alone basically there's
cultural inheritance we have the kind of
nature that requires nurture we have the
kind of genes that require Early
Learning we have we need wiring
instructions from the world to get the
rest of the information that we need to
be competent culturally competent in our
in our in our lives and that starts at
Birth it probably starts before birth
even um but um in the third trimester
there's some evidence of learning fetal
learning even in the third trimester so
um the point is not that people aren't
hardwired for viewing faces or
recognizing faces it's just where does
that hard wirring come from it's not by
genes alone genes aren't the blueprint
the brain is expecting certain inputs
from the world and it needs that because
infant brains are wiring themselves to
their world and part of that world is
people making faces at them and smiling
and those people happen to also be the
ones who are maintaining who are
maintaining that baby's nervous system I
mean there is reward learning right or
reinforcement learning right off the bat
because these are the people who keep
you comfortable they are the ones who
feed you they're the ones who help you
get to sleep and so on and so forth and
so you're going to be very very
sensitive to changes in the
contingencies of their behavior your
brain as a pattern learner is just going
to learn those patterns if we know that
smiling is more you know smiling is a
cue for happiness it's because we've
learned it and that doesn't mean that
that learning isn't hardwired it just
means that it that information got into
your brain by cultural inheritance which
is a part of evolutionary
theory in the extended evolutionary
synthesis not in the original you know
not in the original uh formulation that
some people still kind of stick
to as many of you know I've been taking
ag1 daily since 20 2 so I'm delighted
that they're sponsoring the podcast ag1
is a vitamin mineral probiotic drink
that's designed to meet all of your
foundational nutrition needs now of
course I try to get enough servings of
vitamins and minerals through whole food
sources that include vegetables and
fruits every day but often times I
simply can't get enough servings but
with ag1 I'm sure to get enough vitamins
and minerals and the probiotics that I
need and it also contains adaptogens to
help buffer stress simply put I always
feel better when I take ag1 I have more
focus and energy and I sleep better and
it also happens to taste great for all
these reasons whenever I'm asked if you
could take Just One supplement what
would it be I answer ag1 if you'd like
to try ag1 go to drink a1.com huberman
to claim a special offer they'll give
you five free travel packs plus a year
supply of vitamin D3 K2 again that's
drink a1.com
huberman so it's far more nuanced uh
than it was presented to me in those
textbooks and and it sounds like it was
outright wrong on many dimensions well
can I just mention one thing though
please this is really serious stuff like
sometimes people think well you know
what's the big deal this is such a big
deal I'll tell you why it's a big deal
because in our culture people believe
that they can
read mental states of other people by
their
face and they believe it so much that
it's enshrined in the legal
system and there are people who lose
their lives because juries
believe that they can read remorse or or
the lack of it and in fact there was
just a case um you know last year I
believe where um you know the Innocence
Project uh got involved because there
was a woman who was on death row and
what put her on death row was um a
police officer's claim that he could
read her emotions by her the comportment
of her face and her
body and um and you know uh it was
possible to get a stay of execution so
that she could be retried and you know
um so I'm not saying she was guilty or
not guilty I'm just
saying what put her on death row was
evidence that would not be admissible in
a
scientific um way now um and there are
there are lots of cases where judgments
are made that end up impacting people's
lives in pretty serious ways so this is
a really serious thing and it's um it's
puzzling to
me why it's so it's got such traction
this idea that there are these
Universal um Expressions that we can use
to read each other you know um it's it's
just not true I mean the science just
it's so overwhelmingly I feel like you
know scientists I don't like to use the
t word you know the FW fact you know
it's a scary word t word truth but I
think in this case I feel like I can I
can really at least with a little te I
can I can use it you probably have
particular facial movements that you
make on a regular basis that are tells
for you I know I do you know my husband
can look at my actions and he can make
really decent guesses about what's going
on for me upstairs right but that's
because he's known me for 30 years
actually 30 years today I should just
met each other 30 years ago today but
he's you know brains are pattern
Learners so I'm not saying that
everything is random and like there's no
it's all noise I'm saying that there
just aren't
these you know Universal templates they
just it's not like that and we really
have to stop assuming that that that
there are well I'm so glad that you're
getting that message out there and I'm
very thankful that you highlighted the
seriousness of this um these myths that
have propagated and that's a perfect
segue into what I was already going to
ask which is um it's based on something
that I think is in very much agreement
with what you're saying a previous guest
on this podcast I think it was our first
guest episode Dr Carl di Roth colleague
of mine at Stanford incredible
bioengineer um really you know
0.01% in his you know category of
science as well as a practicing uh
psychiatrist said something which really
stuck with me over the years which I
once heard him say you know we don't
really know how other people feel at all
in fact most of the time we don't even
know how we feel and that prompted the
question for me about how good or poor
are we at gauging our own emotional
states and in particular at labeling
them both to others and for ourselves
and and so here's the the direct
question is language sufficient to
capture this incredibly complex thing
that we're calling emotions so for
instance the other day I was in New York
with my sister then she left I went out
for a bit I was having a pretty good day
and then I returned to the place where I
was staying and I was hit with this
feeling of intense loneliness and I
don't know why and then I had a bunch of
ideas about how that related to growing
up and but I was going to see friends
the next day and I'm an adult and so I
could use some top down regulation and
say oh you know maybe I'm a little tired
or I didn't because I hadn't slept as
well the night before I've been pretty
rested recently and then I actually
wrote in my journal I I said you know
maybe most of feeling good is being
pretty well rested and not in any
physical pain that's a big part of
feeling good is the absence of fatigue
and the absence of physical
pain and and then I thought wow that's
just so basic that's like two bill buing
blocks is clearly insufficient but then
I couldn't think of a word to adequately
describe the emotion that came about an
hour later when I was feeling a little
bit better but not completely better so
was I lonely not really not anymore was
I sad not really but you know as I had
headed out into the city I was thinking
I don't really have a word for how I
feel I'm sort of okay not great not low
you know and so I think that we have
emotional labels I certainly do for Peak
you know these Peak emotional states
super happy I loved the time with my
sister we do this every year this was a
particularly good year for us um to do
this and and it went really well we were
texting back and forth how great it was
I certainly know what it feels like to
be really down in the in the pits I've
got language for that but then there's
this huge range in between and so I
guess the simple question is should we
even trust language as a way
to understand how we're feeling or are
there additional if not better signals
that we should perhaps learn to
elaborate um our understanding of
emotions
with so I'm going to give you a a simple
answer and then I'm going to give you a
more complicated answer right so the
simple answer is no language is not
sufficient period I think the way that
you have well I should say one language
is not sufficient so English is not
sufficient and probably French on its
own is not sufficient and probably
Swahili on its own is not sufficient
although it's very interesting that the
the states that we Mark with words in
each culture some of them overlap but a
lot of them don't and it's very very
useful to have labels of emotion
Concepts from other cultures that that
capture configurations or a state that
we we don't really Mark we don't Mark
those and and sort of distinctively pull
them out as as different from other
states I'd love to know what some of
those are oh there there um I should
have brought them with me I mean there
there are some like there's one there's
a German word which I can't remember the
name of the word but it's like um the
experience of someone having a face that
deserves a punch I'm sure someone will
tell us in the comments someone someone
who knows German or spend time there
please put that word in in the comments
but don't don't punch any another one
that's my favorite is um um liot which
is is um it's a Polynesian um head
hunting um uh emotion word and it
means um exuberant aggression in a
group like soccer or or head
hunting right where you're basically um
or I should say also um in the military
so when I was listening to m one day A
couple of years ago must have been more
than that because it's in my book so it
was probably more than seven years ago
I was listening to these guys talk these
former um um military uh Personnel talk
about being um deployed in a war where
they're with their buddies and
they're they're basically hunting the
enemy and they
feel exuberant like they're you know and
and they're it's not that they're happy
but they're it's Pleasant and it's very
intense very high arousal you know and
in the moment it it seemed right and
then they come back um you know and they
ask themselves like they come back and
so they're now you know their
deployments ended now they're back home
and they're like am I a psychopath like
I enjoy killing people what is this
about and I was thinking no no you just
experienced liot and if you had a word
for it you would understand that it's a
groupy feeling where you're all in it
together and it's really intense and you
know they were experiencing the um the
intensity of of um having their life on
the line and and being responsible for
their for their brothers you know and
sisters in in in their troop you know so
um the the what they would realize is
it's a perfectly it's perfectly within
the range of normal human variation it's
just that in English we don't have a
word for it really but there are words
there are Concepts in other languages
right or the other one that I like is
called gigle which is where when you see
a baby who's really cute and you just
want to like oh you yesterday evening
squee oh my God that kid was so cute
those little cheeks are just like
jumping at you and and the parents are
delightful people too and they was just
facing out cuz they had one of those
outward facing baby things and it's just
sort of like yeah it's and I thinkle
it's called it's gigle gigle oh keigle
is from the other episode that we did on
well it also has to do with babies but
yeah in a different way um or there's
one in I think there's a Japanese
word for the despair that you feel when
you got a bad
haircut really yeah cuz it's I mean it's
really is a different kind of feeling
than you know because you got to like
wait for it to grow up you know whatever
anyways the point being that amazing
words for us Mark particular States and
they're not all the they're not always
the states that other people in other
cultures care about but I there's a but
the even again the phrasing of your
question I just want to come back to and
I'm not trying to pick at you but feel
free what I love is that what what you
said before when you said my question
was illposed in your in the answer that
followed it made it very clear why and I
learned something about how the the the
the not emotion system but the things
plural that that create emotions work so
uh feel free I I I grew up in the same
culture that you did I'm not Canadian by
birth but but in the academic culture
yeah you know I mean the the stuff that
we take online by the way folks is
nothing compared to the kind of hazing
that I experienced growing up in uh in
academic culture as it was done then I
don't know if it's still that way now so
uh feel free yeah I'm tougher than I
look well no I think my point is that
I'm trying to get at here is that when
we ask questions any of us me too
anybody ask a question there are certain
assumptions that we're making in order
to allow us to pose the question and
sometimes what I'm taking issue with is
not the question itself but it's the
assumptions behind the question right
and this is a very classic thing in
philosophy of science which I know I
just said the p word philosophy which
scientists you know usually they roll
their eyes back in their head and fall
over when you talk about that but I
think it's really important so you know
can language is language sufficient to
label or to to to gauge emotional states
kind of sounds like and this is the
assumption that people make that there's
a state in here called an emotion and
now I have to label it I have to
identify it
that is not how it works like that is
not what your brain is doing at all and
in order to explain what I think is
happening and what I my best available
guess you know like based on what I
understand it's like not even remotely
that that is just not a meaningful
question at all um I do think words are
important I just don't think that they
have to be insufficient by virtue of
what the brain is actually doing and the
way that I come at this is just really
different from a lot of my colleagues so
really for a hundred years at least I
hate when people say things like that
like for a hundred years but it really
is like for for a hundred years at least
what psychologists and neuroscientists
do have did and are still doing is they
start with a folk experience a folk
category a common sense experience I
feel angry uh I'm making a decision um
having a memory I'm remembering
something they start with their
experience and then they go looking for
the physical basis of that experience in
the brain or in you know in the
body I think that's really problematic
because not everybody in the world
actually uses those categories or has
those experiences a lot of that has to
do with the scientific publication
process one of the most important
statements I ever heard is from the late
Ted Jones one of the greatest neur
anatomists of probably the last 500
years
um which was the following he said a
drug is a substance that when injected
into an animal or a person produces a
scientific
paper and in many way foot yeah yeah you
kind of catch catch you square in the
face can you go oh right yeah I mean
basically every drug disrupts if taken
an hour or two before sleep changes the
amount of REM sleep that you get so so I
could imagine that almost any
perturbation of the language system the
body the facial movements system could
give you a quote unquote effect that you
could write a paper about yeah but that
doesn't mean it has any semblance
whatsoever to what's happening in the
world when we or other people experience
emotions and here's the here you know
there's so much in what you said that I
I just want to it's very it's very
exciting to talk to you so the first
thing I'll say is that
um you know we often will identify we we
as in the you know people but also
scientists
identify biological
um signals um by what we believe them to
mean psychologically so serotonin is is
a happiness chemical no serotonin
evolved as a metabolic
regulator it is a metabolic regulator
and whatever it's doing it's allowing an
animal to
spend
resources when the animal the animal's
brain isn't sure there's a a reward at
the end of that right so you were saying
before you know the absence of fatigue
the absence of discomfort that's a
that's a pleasant feeling right well
yeah so maybe serotonin has something to
do with pleasantness because it has
something to do with energetics right
cortisol cortisol is not a stress
hormone it's not a stress hormone I mean
it's a hormone that is secreted more
when the brain believes that there is a
big metabolic outlay that's
required that's what stress is basically
it's the brain believes there's a big
metabolic outl that's about to be
required and it matters these kind of
like little semantic tweaks like they
matter a lot because of how we do
because of how we do research so I would
say I don't start with the categories
that derive from English and my own
experience um I start with the nervous
system I try to learn what is the best
available evidence for for how that
nervous system evolved how it developed
how it structured right Anatomy to me is
very important some of my best
hypotheses come from just learning the
anatomy and realizing oh well there's a
connection there that's direct that mean
that should mean something you know I
mean um I could give you lots of
examples of um uh where we've had we've
made discoveries solely because we
noticed an an a set of anatomical
connections and were're really curious
about what they might be involved with
but if you start with that premise then
you think about the brain in I think
about the brain a really different way
right so I don't think about the brain
as a stimulus driven
organ um I think about it more like this
that the the brain is
um first of all the brain is not running
a model or or making inferences about
the world
all the brain knows is are signals from
the sensory surfaces of its body so your
brain is modeling your retina and it's
modeling your ca and it's modeling the
sensory surfaces of the
skin and sure signals you know are you
know hit those surfaces and those
surfaces transduce those signals and
send them up to the
brain but the brain only knows the body
and anything it knows about the world it
knows about the world through the body
through the sensory surfaces of the body
so that's the first for me really big
important point the second important
point is that I think about the brain as
being trapped in a dark silent
box called your skull you know and it's
so weird saying these things to you
you're so much you know you're like
you're this really esteemed like
neuroscientist in here I am explaining
to you how I think the brain works it's
just very you know what's important for
our audience but it's also important for
me even though yes I know I know these
facts but it's I believe it's always uh
informative to go back to the
fundamentals because we forget you know
actually I would say that the uh someone
once described um the I'll call him the
great because he's a great visual
neuroscientist uh visual neuroscientist
Tony maavin who founded the department
of of neuroscience at NYU once said you
know a real intellectual is somebody
that can appreciate and work with a
topic at multiple levels
it's not and oftentimes the more experti
is associated with more focus on detail
so I love returning to the core Basics
so I I think it's wonderful please
please continue so I think about the
brains being trapped in this box and um
it's receiving signals continuously from
the sensory surfaces of the body but
those signals are the outcomes of some
set of changes and the brain doesn't
know what the changes are it doesn't
know the causes of those signals it just
knows the outcomes it knows the signals
that's what it's receiving
and so it has to guess at what the
causes of those signals are in order to
stay
alive
um and so that's in philosophy called an
inverse problem so the brain just has a
massive continuous inverse problem that
it has to deal with all the time like it
can't have it doesn't have access to all
the information no it's just a guessing
machine it's a guessing machine so for
example um you know if you hear a loud
bang what is that loud bang could be a
car door slamming it could be thunder it
could be a car backfiring it could be a
gunshot the brain doesn't know it has to
guess and it's not making a guess like
uh intellectual guess the Guess is a
motor plan it's a plan for changing the
internal state of the body in order to
support motor skeletal motor movements
do I do I need to run do I need to shut
the window do I need to get an umbrella
do I you know do I need to hold my
breath because the car is backfired you
know what do I need to do so where does
that plan come
from well it comes from past experience
the experience that's been wired into
the
brain um what the I think that the
evidence suggests that what the brain is
doing is
basically reinstating
bits and pieces of past experience so
remembering although we don't experience
ourselves as remembering but basically
it's reimplementing ensembles of
signals from the past that are similar
to the present in some
way now a bunch of things which are
similar to each
other in Psychology is a
category so what the brain is doing is
it's creating a it's constructing a
category and in fact we think about the
brain as a continuous category
Constructor it's constructing a category
of possible Futures possible outcomes
possible motor
plans
and how does it know which is the right
one because it's not just picking one
there's going to be some sample that
it's re it's re-implementing but how
does it know which one which is the
right one because there can only be one
well I feel like in the example of a
loud noise
what I immediately thought of as you
were describing that is that my system
would become aware of it I would become
aware of it but then it's a question of
is there another loud noise how closely
are those loud noises spaced is it
getting louder or less loud and then and
so a bunch of categories it it's like a
bookshelf with an infinite number of
books but then with the second loud
noise now it's just you know one uh wing
of the library and then with the the
next thing that happens and the context
it starts narrowing and then pretty soon
you get presented with the book that
says you know the roof is about to cave
in sure and and I think your your PO
your your analogy there is pointing out
two things one is that um really why why
the what the brain is attempting to do
is to reduce
uncertainty because uncertainty is super
expensive now sometimes we like
deliberately you know cultivate
uncertainty right like we do not you
know we deliberately try to learn things
we don't you know that we don't know we
we you know put ourselves novel
situations you know we seek novelty and
because it's fun and interesting and
whatever sure but imagine every single
waking moment of your life was like that
where you didn't know you couldn't
narrow things down from the library to
the wing to the Bookshelf to the you
know the to the the particular shelf on
that bookshelf to yeah you terrifying
yeah it would be that's the label I
would give it it would be terrifying cuz
I couldn't plan anything or do anything
because all possibility are open right
it's and it's just actually
metabolically
unsustainable and you know there are
some there are some brains that are
wired in a way that they don't predict
very well they don't create these
categories very well and so they're
they're dealing
with in really unbelievable amounts of
uncertainty so that's one thing I is but
that part of what's the goal here if you
could say there's a goal is to reduce
uncertainty and I'm going to get why
this has anything to do with emotion in
a minute but I I just need to set up the
ground rules or the assumptions uh you
know of what I'm what I'm working with
here so the other thing though that you
pointed out which I think is really
important is that the um none of this is
static it's all evolving over time right
the signals are evolving over time so
both the signals that are constantly
hitting the sensory surfaces of the body
and making their way to the brain but
also the intrinsic signals in the brain
it's all changing over time so when we
talk about context that's important how
is the brain making a decision about
similarity like what are the features
that are similar it's it's not just at a
single snapshot in time it's always
happening dynamically over time right
and most of the time
though you don't ask your you don't wait
to hear a second sound you don't you're
not deliberately attempting to figure
out what the sound is your brain is just
sorting it out right and it's sorting It
Out by narrowing down the possibilities
and there are some selection mechanisms
in the brain that help it guess better
but also the signals coming from the
world um are are also helping to select
which
possibility um is the right one I'd like
to take a quick break and acknowledge
our sponsor inside track track ER inside
tracker is a personalized nutrition
platform that analyzes data from your
blood and DNA to help you better
understand your body and help you meet
your health goals I'm a big believer in
getting regular blood work done for the
simple reason that many of the factors
that impact your immediate and long-term
Health can only be analyzed from a
quality blood test however with a lot of
blood tests out there you get
information back about blood lipids
about hormones and so on but you don't
know what to do with that information
with inside tracker they have a
personalized platform that makes it very
easy to understand your data that is to
understand what those lipids what those
hormone levels etc mean and behavioral
supplement nutrition and other protocols
to adjust those numbers to bring them
into the ranges that are ideal for your
immediate and long-term Health inside
tracker's ultimate plan now includes
measures of both apob and of insulin
which are key indicators of
cardiovascular health and energy
regulation if you'd like to try inside
tracker you can visit inside tracker.com
huberman to get 20% off any of insid
tracker's plans again that's insid
tracker / huberman to get 20% off
there's this scene that comes to mind
from that movie I think it was Saving
Private Ryan where like the the um the
guys that are about to hit the ground on
D-Day are flinching with every crack of
gunfire like they're just everything's a
stimulus to move and to end and then
some of the more
seasoned soldiers are literally having
bullets whizzing by their head and
people are dropping Dead all around them
and they're moving forward steeli and
stable and upright and in part we look
at that and and say okay they're
courageous they're seasoned maybe
they're desensitized in certain ways but
actually it fits much better with the
idea based on what you're saying it fits
much better with the idea that um they
have intimate knowledge both conscious
and unconscious knowledge that something
right next to them is a threat but not a
threat worth responding to right exactly
but if it were headed straight for them
they would quite quite understand what I
would say it's is that it's um it's not
uh you know I keep referring to things
as signals and really I'm just I'm
that's like my generic word for a
quantity of energy of some sort you know
but your brain my brain every brain is
constantly making signal noise distinct
you know like distinctions do I need to
care about this do I do I not need to
care about this right and we have ways
of learning and we also have ways of
queuing each other so um you know humans
use eye gaze to cue each other about
what is signal and what is noise right
so if you and I were sitting or let's
say we were at a coffee shop and we were
in a part of town that i' had never been
to before and we were sitting having
coffee and you know a loud siren went by
if you turned and looked i' would
probably turn and look because you just
cued me that that was something I need
to care about if you ignored it I'd
probably ignore it because you just cued
me that I I didn't need to worry about
it I didn't need to care and we're
constantly doing that with each other
and we also do it with little babies and
with kids and that's how we teach
children this is signal this is noise
this you need to worry about this you
can ignore and so yeah your your
description is perfect so what does this
have to do any of this have to do with
emotion in order to answer that part of
the question I I I want to
say so okay you've got these signals the
brain is like has these electrical
signals going on we'll just ignore the
hormonal signals for the moment because
that's complic you know one is
complicated so it's got all these
electrical signals going on it's when
it's remembering something it's just
basically reinstating a pattern of
signals and it's got these signals
coming in um from the sensory servfaces
okay so what's so what is the brain
doing it's a signal processor so what is
it I don't mean a computer I mean a
signal processor in the engineering
sense so what's it what is it doing
without getting into all the Dynamics
of prediction and you know whatever what
the brain is doing is it's um it's
assembling a set of
features it's some of the features that
it's assembling are very close in detail
to the sensory surfaces of the body so
in primary visual cortex there's a
retinotopic map the details there are
very very low level like a line an edge
you know same thing in primary auditory
cortex right it's tonotopic so there are
tones
but it's very very very lowlevel details
and we might there are many many many
many of these little features so we
would say there there's a it's a high
dimensional array lots and lots and lots
and lots of features and then and let's
just talk about one structure just the
cerebral cortex let's not worry about
just but what I'm about to say is
basically true of really the rest of the
brain as well if you take the cortex off
the surface uh the cortical sheet off
the that wavy you know cortical sheet
you take it off the rest of the brain
the subcortical parts and you stretch it
out like a napkin you can see there's a
compression gradient there in the
architecture of the neurons so at the
primary sensory areas there are these
tiny little paramal neurons that are
representing these little these very
low-level features and they feed into
bigger neurons which feed into bigger
neurons which feed into more bigger
neurons so what's happening is you've
got this very detailed array
being compressed in its dimensionality
until you get to the middle of the brain
at the front where there are many fewer
neurons but they're bigger and they have
many more connections so it's a
dimensionality reduction that's
happening so just to make sure I
understand um correctly and that the
audience understands the physical world
obviously is um transformed by our
sensory apparati the retina the ca the
the sensing neurons in our skin
umal things mechan pressure phon sound
waves okay that's translated into neural
code which is chemical and electrical
yeah and and those sensory inputs are
are fairly vast and you call high
dimension high dimensionality so lots of
different orientations of lines lot even
you know even though it originates with
just three uh cone photop pigments lots
of opportunity for encoding different
shades of color contrast okay and all of
that so you have lots of little neurons
to represent all the possibilities of
the physical world that are occurring MH
but as that information is passed
further up along EXC I have to be
careful with the use of hierarchies
because that's controversial nowadays
not for political reasons but for
accuracy reasons um as that information
is passed along there's more um
convergence onto a smaller number of
larger neurons so these are neurons that
have access to a lot of information but
in coarser form right so there are low
you know it's like like compressing an
MP3 like how an MP3 compresses
information for example so the cortex is
representing
features so and I represent I'm just
using that in a generic way because
that's also controversial about exactly
how is the okay but yeah but it works
but for now I'm using it just in a
generic way so you go from lines and
edges to a shape like a round shape to a
face to a right so you're you're
basically you're you're um you're going
what's happening is there are
summaries of summaries of summaries of
summies I love that I hope everyone
hears that because I've been in this
field of Neuroscience a long time as you
move along the neur axis from the
sensory epithelium now it sounds very
very Gomen clish but from the surface of
the skin inward you're getting summaries
yeah they send more and more summaries I
think that's so important I that's a
that's a like a gazillion dollar
statement for understanding of the
nervous system so but each of those
points correspond to some mental feature
like a line or an edge or a circle or a
square or a face or right but but now
then you when you when you're in the
midline at the front what are those
features well those features are things
like they are they are multimodal
summaries meaning they are summaries of
the sights and sounds and smells and
right but they and they are lower
dimensional meaning they are they're
coarser so there are things like threat
reward
pleasure I mean really abstract that's
what abstract means it doesn't mean that
those representations have no sensory or
motor meaning it means that threat for
example a
summary can have many different patterns
associated with it and the brain is
treating them all as equivalent this
this to me again feels so so important
for people to understand because um as
I'm hearing this and this word summaries
is just ringing in my mind it's so
important because one of the core
components of my experience of my
emotions because that's all I can really
say for sure my
subjective interpretation and labeling
of my own emotions is that they are
pretty broad bins like I described ear
pretty broad bins and so that that's
where I was exactly where I was going
so what about the word anger where is
that represented like well that's a
that's a one of these multimodal
abstractions in fact anger is just a
couple of phones it's a couple of sounds
but those sounds the sound of anger
corresponds over thousands of instances
that you've learned in your life to very
different patterns of sensory motor
features that's right because what's
going on in your
body during anger can vary what the way
you move your face in Anger can vary
depending on the situation what you see
someone else doing in Anger can vary and
so the word anger or any word is
actually just a multi Al summary of many
many many many instances which are in
their sensory and motor features the
sensory and motor meaning very different
and and it seems to me are highly
constrained by Developmental and
cultural experience absolutely because
just today I learned that there's a word
in Japan for the feeling that one has of
having gotten a haircut they don't like
there's a word in Germany
that pertains to the feeling of wanting
to punch someone specifically because of
the look on their face well really it's
more like you like you they to you it
feels like they're asking to be punched
in the face even so you added yet more
dimensionality to it so upon learning
just those things just today there is
additional dimensionality brought in
such that if I were to ever um want to
punch somebody in the face simply
because of the look on their
face that I wouldn't NE necessarily
label that as anger alone it now has
another dimension to it and so I I think
I'm finally I think I'm finally starting
to understand how the Developmental and
the cultural influences plus the fact
that language is a pretty crude
descriptor for this neural process that
you're describing oh absolutely
absolutely but okay so but but before
you use the word granularity and so I'm
going to use that word too in fact I've
you I've coined that phrase emotional
granularity
um just as an aside you know I coined
that phrase almost 30 years ago and now
people study it like it's a phenomenon
which is cool in a sense but also I kind
of want to keep reminding them like
that's a word that refers to a process
it's not a thing it's a process and the
but the process
is so when the brain is a category
Constructor
how fine grained are the categories how
size of the categories right like if
you're using if your feature of
equivalence that your brain is using is
threat you're in really big trouble
because there are like a gazillion
different sensory motor patterns that
could go with threat so your category is
going to be massive so how does the
brain figure out which of those massive
number of options is the one to use in
this in in this instance if on the the
other hand you don't just want to use
sensory motor patterns as the features
of equivalence or the features that
you're using to say this instance right
now is similar to these past instances
if I had to search like right now what
is similar to right now it would be me
sitting across the table from somebody
who has a beard and is um dressed in
black and you know there there are a lot
of details there that probably don't
matter right so you you'd be searching
for a specific match from the past
that's not very efficient either so you
need something in the
middle and that that is to say you need
to have C your brain has to be able to
make categories that are more fine
grained but not super fine grained but
they have to be more fine grained than
just threat yeah you want to keep the in
the library analogy that I made earlier
you want to keep the rest of the library
accessible at some level yeah so you're
not just staring at that one book but if
you use the
category bad this feels bad
then your brain is
basically um going to
be partially constructing an entire Wing
full of books like a entire Wing full of
options if you use the word
angry um then maybe it's a bookcase it's
constructing a bookcase full of options
and a category that's the size of a
bookcase and if you were using the word
frustrated then maybe it's a shelf the
brain can learn to construct categories
at different scales of gen
generalizability so if I'm in an
instance and um my brain is making a
guess is it drawing from past instances
that were associated with the word
anger uh were associated with the word
fear maybe it's some combination it's
the words are just features they're just
sounds there are also all sorts of other
features like what was my heart doing
what what what kind of motor actions did
I make what did I see next so the point
being what I'm trying to bring here is
that it's not like your brain creates an
emotional state and then labels it what
your brain is doing is creating a
category of possible futures of what's
going to H what it's going to do next
and that state is largely determined by
the what the brain is remembering and
it's drawing from that huge population
that huge library of options which books
is it sampling I love this so much
because it explains so much that frankly
has been perplexing to me and also
somewhat troubling to me like for
instance I um we hear about emotional
intelligence you know and and sometimes
I wonder whether or not um true
emotional intelligence would be what you
just described the understanding of how
this process works so that you can work
with it and I definitely want to talk
about how one can work with this
knowledge because I think it's
incredibly powerful in its um
explanatory power but also um it's
actionable power um the other thing is
that it's clear to me just based on my
experience today of hearing these words
from other cultures that relate to
different emotional states that this
system unlike a lot of systems in the
brain I like to think is fairly plastic
yeah like the moment that you know that
there are additional Dimensions to
sadness Etc there's something comforting
about that what's really unsettling is
the idea that we have such broad bends
that we are we would Define you know a
near infinite number of situations as
just fear that would suck that's not a
good existence and yet I have to ask
whether or not you think that as a
species not as a culture but our entire
species whether or not we are taking the
exact opposite approach that we're sort
of moving into the Emoji
isation is that a word I'll make it a
word and people can assault me in the
comments um the
emojiz of this very rich and complex
system we're starting to get into this
mode of like I'm going to post an angry
face and therefore like this is a bad
I'm angry at you this is a bad
interaction we're going to it's it's um
combat potentially combative or and you
know maybe um Twitter X or Instagram or
other social media sites are kind of the
the epitome of this where you reduce
this High dimensional space in you you
keep the the sensory stimulation very
high it's movie after movie after movie
and color and sound and people doing
crazy parkour stuff and bears eating
giraffes or whatever it is probably not
bears eating giraffes but you know what
I mean and you can see stuff that's
sexual and violent and political and
emotional and sweet and then the cats
are kissing the monkey and you're like
or the monkey's kissing the cat and so
it's high dimensionality in terms of
sensory space but then what do we call
it we're like oh this is an emoji you
ass sign an emoji you're heting
something you're giving a thumbs up or a
thumbs down so I almost feel like we
we're trying to uh we we're regressing
to a state where we're kind of like an
infant trying to figure out like what
the hell is going on and we're saying
you know what you get like six
categories of response when in reality
um we should probably be expanding the
number of different responses that we
can have in order to accurately match
the way that our nervous system actually
works yes exactly there are many
different things we could talk about
with respect to the summary that you
just gave which I I think is completely
accurate so what I would say is that if
you look through even just the last I
don't know hundred or so years like the
19th you know 19th 20th centuries maybe
you can see that the complexity of the
of people's
responses expands and contracts right so
for example this is something that I've
written really speculatively about
um but one of the things that I found
really interesting um is that you know
authoritarianism authoritarian thinking
is the reduction of complexity to some
things that are really really simple
like you're getting rid of all the
complexity to you know basically these
very very coarse low dimensional
judgments and Things become black and
white um it's the avoid of
complexity um so that there can be
simple single answers to things and it
happens in human culture at times and
then then there's an expansion of
complexity at times too so what predicts
that like what is it in the human
nervous system or our Collective human
nervous you know like we're we're just a
bunch of brains attached to bodies
interacting with other brains and bodies
right so like what is it that causes
these um ripples of and and I have some
thoughts about that that are really
really really
speculative um but I think the other
thing that's that's really important is
that we've talked about we'll go back to
our our cortical sheet that we've and by
the way this is just one compression
gradient in the brain there are others
too right um there are at least four
others that I can think of um so this is
just one but all compression gradients
work the same way which is that now
we've talked about going from the
low-level details um compressing to
these multimodal summaries these really
like simple um features that are right
but that
compression is what Engineers would call
lossy meaning you lose the
information you lose the
information so when you go from lines
and edges to a face those neurons they
just know the face they don't have they
lose what they've thrown away the
details they've thrown away those
details are gone for those neurons that
are representing a face they don't have
access to that they don't have access to
it you know so we said well the brain is
making a guess it's making a guess about
what these what this big very very
high-dimensional you know soup of
signals in the world and in the body
like what do they mean
right when the brain makes a guess it
starts with the compressed low
dimensional sign it starts with the
features like anger or like threat or it
starts with these summaries and then it
has to infer or guess at every synapse
there's a guess that's being made about
what the details are at the next level
because what's happening is the guess is
basically the brain going from these
really General things to these very
specific sensory motor patterns it
happens along the cortical sheet it
happens also down the Nur axis down the
ner you know from the cortex to the
midbrain to the brain stem to the spinal
cord you have to go from a
representation of you know run to the
actual physical movements of muscles
spindles and you know angles of joints
and things like that so what you're
doing is you're going in the other
direction you're adding detail you're
particularizing and the brain is
guessing it's guessing well if it's
using anger as the general feature well
which which instance of anger is it and
what are the specifics that are going to
happen and and what are the WT and
forgive me but and what are the Adaptive
steps that I might take or not take
because um I'm quoting a lot today so
forgive me but in the words of the great
sharington Nobel prize winning
physiologist the final common pathway is
movement is movement and that's and and
movement is nuanced right humans I I
suppose have among the greatest variety
of different speeds and types of
movement I think about parkour or
gymnastics think about then what like a
a cheetah can do cheetah are impressive
a gymnist is truly impressive in terms
of the range of movements and speeds Etc
in any event the ultimate choice of the
nervous system has to make is whether or
not to
move which direction how fast or stay
still move move back and and I just I'll
just add because I'm I'm hoping that
you'll expand on this um it's been said
before that ultimately the nervous
system is trying to make decisions about
yum yuck or me like like am I going to
move towards something am I going to
move away from it or am I just going to
stay put well that's only that's only at
the that that's a very I would say that
those are very low dimensional features
those are those compressed features but
that's not the only thing the brain has
to decide that's just a misnomer well
good that I can get out of this little
pickle that I just put myself in by
saying that I didn't say that now I
won't quote who did because he's a very
famous neuroscientist but he tried to
reduce it all he's at Caltech it um he's
not somebody who studies emotion he
studies the visual system but he said
that you know that that there's a that
the the neural circuits maybe it's
because he studies mice are are
essentially bended into um yum yuck and
meh outputs and and i' I've always liked
it on the one hand cuz threes work and
it's simple but rarely is the way that
we describe things the way it actually
works so we would you know in in
studying humans we would say well that's
affect affect that's mood or you know
it's just like is it is it um should I
move towards it is it Pleasant should I
move away from it is it unpleasant or
you know is it irrelevant basically I
don't care okay think about when you're
feeling horrible you just feel you feel
you just feel you feel bad what do you
do you don't know what you don't know
because you don't have a plan of action
and that's ultimately that is what those
those compressed like summary features
those very low coarse features they have
to be decompressed into details
otherwise you don't know what to do so
ultimately what the brain is doing is
it's sampling from the
past based
on similarity to the present to plan an
action and when I say action I don't
just mean skeletal motor action like
moving a limb it you the first actions
that are planned are the actions of
coordinating the heart and the lungs and
you know all of the internal actions
that are required to support the motor
the skeletal motor movements so your
brain is making uh is categorizing and
it's making a it's it's creating a
category and it's there are options
there those options the motor plans
begin with should the heart beat faster
should it beat slower does blood
pressure need to go up should the you
know should the blood vessels constrict
or should they dilate um should the
breathing be deeper or more shallow I
mean those are the first plans that get
made and then milliseconds later there
are the skeletal motor plans and then
your experience of the world derives
from those motor plants those viscero
motor that is the plans for the viscera
for the internal organs and the skeletal
motor so I'm just going to refer to them
as motor those motor plans actually give
rise to your experience of the world
there's not some state that exists as an
emotional state which then you apply a
label to the
label is a just a set of
features that are useful for
generalizing from the past to the
present and the bin size or the the you
know of of what a word refers to can
change it can change it's different for
different people and it can change in
your lifetime and you can add new Bins
that is you can so for example there's a
there's a concept gusin look which I
probably just butchered so if you speak
Turkish I'm sorry but it's like um it
has features of it of like loss and um
like people blocking your goals so we
would say it's anger and sadness
together that's gusin look when you lose
something and you're pissed off about it
um that's a but that's a category on its
own right it's just a different way of
parsing that that that really detailed
soup and the more words you know the
more words are just useful
for pointing to a set of features that
are similar to each other so what I mean
by that is if I say to you Andrew I had
pizza last night for dinner pizza two
sounds two
syllables that those two syllables s
they stand in for like 50 different
sensory and motor
features because I don't have to say to
you I had a food I didn't have pizza L
thing but let's say I did I had a food
that was round and flat and had sauce
and also cheese and it it had mozzarella
cheese and also a little parmesan cheese
and it had mushrooms on it and a little
bit of uh Olive and you know um that's
like really really uh detailed and
complicated but instead I can just say I
had pizza two features two sounds two
syllables
phones and with those two
phones I have just communicated to you
in your brain my brain had 50 features
it was representing of details and now I
have just communicated those to you or
some number of them with two sounds very
efficient now of course you might think
that I was from Chicago and had deep
dish pizza and I'll just resist I don't
I don't want to like offend anybody from
Chicago it's not pizza that's not real
pizza that's not real Pizza um right so
you could then ask me uh was it but
you're from Chicago is that deep dish
pizza and then I would say no no I'm
actually from Toronto which is just like
New York and so no it was thin crust
pizza which is really the only kind of
pizza there is just saying but you know
but my point is that words are just
stand in for they're just low these low
dimensional features these these s of
gross features that stand in for many
many many many little detailed features
and that's how we communicate with each
other and and we are constrained by you
know what we know and our yes so and
what we can say and the extent of our
vocabulary and I'll just say that little
babies three months old they don't speak
yet and they don't understand language
but they can use words to learn abstract
categories so abstract just means that
the the word refers to many different
patterns of sensory motor features so
the word is um or the category the
things that make the instances similar
um are a function um or goal not like
the sensory motor features so you say to
a
baby very explicitly like because if
we're talking about three four-month-old
babies right babies can also do this
implicitly too um but in experim exp you
say to a baby look
sweetie this is a bling and you put the
bling down and it makes a beeping noise
and then you say now this looks
different feels different right smells
different look sweetie this is a
bling it
beeps now you take something
else which also is different and you say
look sweet this is a
bling now the baby expects this to beep
by the way folks just listening Lisa
just gave three examples first with a
pen then a coffee mug and then her very
own watch uh three very distinct objects
but all of which make uh that are told
uh the baby is told make uh a bling
sound and they will bend those three
yeah visual distinct objects
functionally distinct objects into one
single bin because they make a because
they are sharing a function which is to
beep I think this is so so important and
I um and if I may I I I want to ask
whether or not we can take this
incredible understanding of emotions
because that's really what we're talking
about well we're really talking about
how the brain my my version of how the
brain works and how emotions emerge out
of this system basically and and
absolutely um you described it far
better than I could and and and anchor
that to this concept of movement like
the movement is the final common path
with the understanding that the movement
system and forgive me but that we have
systems in the brain and body that allow
us to move that's for sure systems
plural that they run in both directions
in other words how we feel what we
feel our emotions has some bearing on
the movements that are more or less
likely for us in a given context and our
movements clearly can also influence the
way that we feel internally well it's
well I mean so if um if we just look at
how things are happening here's here's
what the anatomy tells us that when the
brain makes a guess that guess starts as
a motor plan starts as a visceral motor
plan and a skeletal motor plan so heart
rate changes breathing changes blood
pressure changes and potentially
skeletal muscle movement right and
literal copy
literal copies efferent copies of those
signals are sent to they propagate to
the sensory areas telling the brain
telling those neurons this is the last
time we made this in this context when
this other stuff just happened the like
this temporal context right the and we
made these movements here is what we saw
next here is what we felt next here's
what we smelled next so yeah I think of
this so the image that Pops in my mind
and we should explain to people what
efference copy is um in neuroscience and
neuro Anatomy uh the connection to a
structure is called an aarant with an A
and the connections out from a structure
are called the eer but the way I was say
it doesn't even matter it's just
basically the point here is that in our
experience in our in the way the brain
your brain conjures an experience okay
and and that experience is that you feel
something first you see something you
feel something you act that's not what's
happening what's happening is your brain
is preparing the action first and the
feeling what and your experience comes
from that action preparation so it's a
copy it's like literally you have axons
that are sending motor signals down the
the you know brain stem to the spinal
cord and literal copies of those axons
like those axons have branches that
collateral branches that just send axons
other places the same signal that is
being sent to your spinal cord to move
stuff in your body that same signal is
being sent to other neurons in the brain
as predictions of the sensations that
are going to happen in a second from now
a moment from now probably faster than a
second but you know in a couple
milliseconds if you move and so yes it
is the case that what you feel is linked
to what you do and what you do is linked
to what you feel but not in this simple
mechanistic way that that
neuroscientists and psychologists have
been using
forever you it's not like you are you
are you you're probed by a stimulus you
you see something you hear something and
then you process it and evaluate it and
then you react to it no that's not
what's happening what's actually
happening under the hood is that based
on how things are right now your brain
makes a guess or some guesses and those
guesses start as motor
plans and the consequence of those motor
plans are predicted Sensations and then
of course sensory signals are coming
from the sensory surfaces and they s and
here's the really here's to me the
really the most mind-boggling thing
about this whole
explanation if your Sensory neurons in
your sensory areas are already so
they're firing the the the the action
potentials the spiking has changed based
on these prepared motor movements these
are sensory
predictions and you know when I give
talks and on my website I have some cool
examples of of how this works you can
experience it yourself you you know
start to experience uh you know you hear
things that aren't there you you feel
vibrations in your chest that aren't
there because your brain is predicting
it's predicting these
Sensations so let's say the sensations
come the the sensory signals I should
say let me so the sensory signals from
the sensory surfaces of the body make it
to the
brain if you have if your neurons are
already firing in a way to anticipate
those signals those signals just confirm
the firing and then they're done they
don't make it any further into the
brain so when you're predicting
well your experience is constructed
completely by your brain the signals
from the sensory surfaces are there just
to confirm irm
or to change the signals so if there's
things you didn't
anticipate then those um errors of
prediction those are the signals that
are propagated and become compressed and
stuff and we have a special name for
that in science we call it learning you
know Andy Clark is a philosopher who
writes a lot about prediction predicting
brain and and so on and he talks about
normal uh everyday experience as being a
controlled
hallucination I think that's true yeah I
subscribe to that um it's a fairly
adaptive in most circumstances
controlled hallucination but but it has
its limitations and it I mean what we
were talking about um if I could be a
somewhat of a summary neuron you can
tell me if my summary is too coarse um
is that first of all that the neural
systems and the Brain let's just call it
the nervous system because we're talking
about brain and body are incredibly
Dynamic there's a bunch of inputs those
inputs gets are incredibly elaborate
they get summarized the summary prepares
the body for a certain action that's a
motor commands preo commands and then
some action may or may not be taken but
already as soon as an action is taken or
not taken the whole state of the neural
system is different it's changed as a
consequence of just of what just
happened now of course when people hear
that and when I hear that indeed I I
feel like wow it's a tough system to
study because these are dynamical neural
systems and and we have the technology
to put people in functional scanners and
look at what lights up so to speak we
have the capacity to ask people how they
feel based on questionnaires but you can
imagine that's incredibly crude so then
you give them liyer scales of you know
rate from 1 to 10 how happy or sad you
are and so you're adding some some depth
and dimensionality to it but it's
incredibly crude it's nothing like real
experience and if somebody's more verbal
less verbal maybe they somaticize more
or less I mean an example comes to mind
that you know occasionally you learn
from social media which often I learn
from social media and someone once said
I don't think in thoughts I think in
feels and I thought okay great you're
probably also from Northern California
and I said wait Andrew stop being so
judgmental what do you mean and I asked
and they said I experience emotions in
their mind first as a as a bodily State
then the label comes much later that's
not how it works for me it feels fairly
more integrated brain and body for me
but other people started chiming in no I
think of emotion I experience emotions
clearly as a verbal label it's all in
their head and so you start to realize
that we might all be encoding The World
Slightly differently or very differently
and it's changing in time so then the
question becomes you know how what are
the anchor points in terms of our
understanding of emotions that we can
work with and and and the following
questions come to mind um neither you
nor I are clinicians as far as I know
I'm certainly not I was actually trained
as a clinician oh there you go I'm wrong
again but I haven't no no no but I mean
I haven't I haven't practiced in like
really gazillions of years okay well
you're you're well you're more than
qualified to answer the question I'm
about to ask which is to me there is a
great conflict of information in the
psychology Psychiatry and let's just
call it wellness and mental health space
which is when we are feeling lousy like
not good let's put veilance on it just
lousy I don't want in a state that we
we're having an emotion that we don't
want to
have there's an entire category of
information that says you need to feel
your feelings you need to feel your
feelings you need to acknowledge that
they're there you need to go into the
feeling maybe even full catharsis you
need to amplify the feelings until they
quote unquote leave your body after all
Steve Job was into scream therapy and
helped himun his anger who knows you get
these examples he's probably the worst
example because it seemed like he was
angry a lot from what I hear but then
there's another category of thought
which is no you need to use your ability
to top down control inhibition of the
cortex on Lower structures again I'm
deliberately using crude language here
to say wait you know this is an emotion
emotions pass this is not real this is
just a limited set of uh High
dimensionality stuff that's been
summarized and you know what like I
don't need to feel this way I can make
myself feel differently maybe I'll go
for a run in fact I always feel better
after I go for a run so even this
question as simple as should we feel our
our
feelings or should we not feel our
feelings and of course you would hope
that this would be answered
appropriately such that people don't go
harm other people or themselves but but
but assuming that they're not going to
harm other people eles verbally or
physically then you really get yourself
into a bit of a pickle like we don't
understand what to do with
emotions ours or other people's because
clearly we don't understand emotions per
se so I would say I'm going to answer
your question and then I want to also
pick it the word the I want to pick it
an
assumption um because it it's come up
actually a couple of times and there's
something super important in your
descriptions that I just want to pull
out for for the listeners because I
think it's really important and you're
doing it very naturally but I think some
people it would be it just Bears
commenting on so let me just deal with
the question of should we feel our
feelings or use our words you know we
say to little kids use your words like
don't throw a tantrum right um but then
there was also this other feeling oh
just feel it's important to feel and you
don't want to get it have it be pent up
and you or use your body and like and
like hit a pillow I mean there's scream
therapy bite the pillow SC pill tear the
pillow's you can p $5,000 for a week
ofing this and they'll tell you you're
going to feel better at the end so the
answer there is it's the wrong question
like flexibility is important for
everything always right so um first of
all you don't have you don't have
emotions in your body your body doesn't
keep the score you know yeah great book
title because it's super catchy but with
all due respect to I think the important
work of Vander I think it oversimplified
and led people to believe that their
back pain was
trauma and that all trauma is somatized
and it's not no it's not but I I would
go further and say like first of all
your body does keep the score your brain
keeps the score your body is the
scorecard that's super important and he
has done really important work but his
explanations for why things work is
scientific ific Al
incorrect it just is because we don't
feel things in our bodies we everything
we feel we feel in our brains we don't
see in our eyes we see in our brains of
course we need our eyes but we don't see
in our eyes just like if you you know
pinch your your hand with you know take
skin and pinch between you know two two
fingers the skin you don't feel that
actually in your hand you feel it in
your brain that's the magic of the brain
in a sense so what I would say is it
um uh it depends on the situation and
what your goal
is um sometimes it is useful to use your
words and sometimes it is useful to go
for a
run it just depends on what your goal is
well in both those cases you're you're
uh that you gave both those examples
excuse me you're um it's a way of
Shifting off the emotion I guess what
I'm asking is well sometimes you don't
want to shift off the emotion sometimes
the mo sometimes the wisest thing to do
is live in the emotion that is you know
sometimes uh
discomfort sometimes when something
feels bad it doesn't mean something is
wrong it just might mean that you're
doing something hard well earlier I
wrote when you talking about the the
broad categorization of emotions I I
wrote down you know simple as good when
it feels good you're like I just feel
really great but then when things feel
lousy that's where Nuance could be
beneficial yeah AB absolutely because
we're because emotions are recipes for
Action when you go from be feeling bad
to feeling angery or sad it's a recipe
for action and I would also say and this
just this is an analogy but I I sort of
I stand by it um you know uh when I was
um I had major back surgery a couple
years ago and I know something about
chronic pain it's not my area of study
but I know something about it because
I've I've and reanalyze some some data
sets and I've read a lot so I'm not an
expert but you know I have ideas and I
thought to myself well I just I don't
want to end up with chronic back pain so
what I did was I made sure after I got
through the first couple of weeks where
I really needed oxycodone so that I
could walk you know I was up and walking
the same day I had surgery if you could
call it walking it sort of a euphemism
for like hobbling around on a with a
walker but um I made sure that I felt
the
pain that is I dosed myself with
discomfort quite deliberately because I
wanted to make sure that I'm I'm I'm
sorry for using you know cartisian
language I don't know how else to say
this I I wanted my brain to be taking in
the prediction error I wanted my brain
to to feel the to to I wanted to focus
attention on the changing dis you know s
the the changing discomfort over time
because it meant that my body was
healing as the discomfort got less but
my brain would never feel that
discomfort changing if I uh took
painkillers
and because the prediction error the
things that the brain doesn't predict
are teaching signals and I think it's
true also in your life like sometimes
you want to feel it because you you want
to feel the discomfort because it's
instructive about something and
sometimes it's not and that's maybe
that's not really an answer but the only
way that you can figure that out for
yourself is to do it sometimes if you're
always getting rid of discomfort you
never know when it's useful and it is
useful sometimes but now I want to get
to this point that I was making before
like we are talking about feeling and
emotion interchange like they're
interchangeable and they're not right so
here's how I would say it your brain is
always regulating your body
247 and your body is always sending
sensory signals back to the brain about
the sensory state of the
body and our nervous systems aren't
wired for us to experience those sensory
changes that are happening in the body
in any degree of
detail we're just not and it's a good
thing like right now as we talk here our
hearts are beating and our you know pain
pancreas is squishing stuff out you know
liver is you know filtering and like you
know oxygen concentrations are changing
like a there's a whole drama going on
inside each of us and our listeners and
we're largely not aware and I hope our
listeners aren't aware because if they
were they would not be listening to
anything we were saying they'd be
completely you know in enraptured or or
in discomfort at what's going on inside
them instead the brain creates a
low-dimensional summary this gross kind
of like barometer which is feeling
affective feeling we call it or you
could call it mood but scientists call
it affect with an A Feeling Pleasant
feeling unpleasant feeling worked up
feeling calm feeling comfortable feeling
uncomfortable it's kind of a general
barometer of the state of the body and
it's not emotion that those feelings
those features of feeling are features
of consciousness because your brain is
always regulating your body your body's
always sending signals back to the brain
the brain is always representing them in
this low-dimensional way whether you're
paying attention or not like whether the
brain is focusing it's you know applying
attention to those neurons or not the
those signals are
there and even when we're not
emotional you know like if you're
driving on the highway and somebody cuts
you off and you think what an
the assholeness of that person that
intensity of that negative affect is you
experience it as a property of that
person but really it's coming from you
it's it's not a property of that person
it's that's a feature of your experience
in that
moment and affect is always there
sometimes it's in the foreground
sometimes it's in the background but
it's always there and it's a summary of
physical things which is why it helps to
if you take ibuprofen or Tylenol it will
redu I mean study show it reduces
negative feeling if you go for a run if
you go for a walk if you shift your
attention to the outside
world then the features that of
experience that are derived from the
inside World diminish that's why going
for a run helps or going for a walk
helps or you know getting sleep helps
right these are all things where you're
changing the state of your body and so
the sensory state of your body is
changing and so your affect changes but
emotions are the story that the brain
tells about what caused the sensory
signals that affect derives from so what
caused those changes what do I need to
do about those changes that's that's
like it's a it's a much
bigger event than just these features of
experience which are all features of
Consciousness which are always there
they're always there and in in
fact in our
culture we we pathologize people when
they just experience their bodies as
physical Sensations and not as emotions
like we say oh that person is Som
somatizing or somatizing they're not
they should they're really they're they
should be experiencing emotion but
really they're you know experiencing a
stomach ache and that's bad but that's
actually a judgment call that is
probably sometimes wrong sometimes it's
probably better to experience a stomach
ache sometimes it's more productive part
of being emotionally intelligent is
knowing when not to construct an
emotion you know like uh right before Co
the coid pandemic was announced
officially I was in New Zealand giving
talks and my
daughter who was who was in college at
that time was
flying uh literally like
I think less than a week before the
pandemic was announced she got on a
plane and she flew to New Zealand to
meet me because it was spring break and
I always would bring her with me on
spring
break and in that and I remember really
vividly I was in New Zealand there was
only one case one case of coid in New
Zealand at that point and I I got on the
phone to my husband and I
said I'm experiencing a very high level
of arousal and it's it's very very
unpleasant now my husband knows me very
well and he said yeah there's a lot of
uncertainty and I said I know now he
didn't say to me well you're anxious and
you just don't really know it I because
I wasn't anxious I was feeling
uncertain and as you know or maybe
people are know that when there's a lot
of uncertainty there's also a lot of
arousal because the brain is attempting
to learn and the neurom modulators that
are important for learning new things
happen to also cause uh a subjective
sense of arousal and some they actually
also modulate your autonomic nervous
system so your heart can beat faster and
whatever and our go-to explanation for
what that is is to experience that
arousal as anxiety but I was uncertain
and remember that how your brain the
story it's telling itself the category
it's making is a plan for action well
what do you do in anxiety and fear you
freeze or you run away what do you do in
uncertainty you forage for information
you tolerate the discomfort and you
forage for information which is what I
was doing when I called and said what
should we do should I meet her at the
airport and turn around and come back or
should we have a vacation like I don't
really know um and you know what I ended
up doing was foraging for information
for another couple days and then made a
Split Second decision in the air when we
were flying from one Island to the other
and we just re-rooted us and we went
home and then the borders closed like
two days later you know but my point is
that it this is not just you
know
uh psychological mumbo jumbo you can
train yourself to
experience your heart pounding in your
chest as determination what when my
daughter this is all in how emotions are
made these examples but they're true I
mean my daughter this is the this book I
wrote a couple years ago when my
daughter was 12 years old she was
testing for a black belt in karate she
was 5 feet tall not even and she was
testing against these like massively
large adolescent boys okay who were like
a foot taller than her and her Sensei
who was a 10th degree black belt didn't
say to her don't be afraid
he said get your butterflies flying in
formation and I was like in raptured I
was like oh my God this guy is totally
brilliant that is the
best you know meaning to give to
arousal that changes the meaning of it
what you do when you create an emotion
is you're giving meaning to those
affective
feelings and you have have more
control than you might think in how you
do that you can do it by changing the
physical state that gives rise to those
feelings but you can also change it by
learning more how to make more
categories and how to make them more
fluidly um so that you do something
different
and the it's not that things will
necessarily feel any more unpleasant or
any less or or any more pleasant it's
that
the feeling becomes a source of wisdom
it's a cue to do something
different this is a case uh where I
absolutely believe that uh knowledge
about how emotions and affect and states
of the brain and body work which is what
you're beautifully describing for people
today is extremely useful in and of
itself and I think um and I it's a
frankly it's a it's a refreshing and
welcome departure from a lot of the
conversations that we normally have on
this podcast where you know we talk a
lot about protocols we talk about tools
right things that people can do ways
they can implement the knowledge and
here this is certainly one of those
cases as well but um it's a beautiful
one and a very um important one
where the knowledge itself just the
knowledge of additional words for
different states uh I love the example
example of butter putting butterflies
into formation because it it inherent to
that is that you're not trying to get
rid of the Butterflies quite the
opposite yeah um you're deploying them
in certain ways and there's an action
step and a psychological step there of
course that's required but that it isn't
um you know view morning sunlight for an
average of 10 minutes to set your
circadian rhythm which is something that
I say over and over again I'll go into
the grave saying that they'll probably
put a window over my grave so sunlight
can get in at this point but which would
be fine with me but in any case um
knowledge is power is something that we
hear but it's not always true often it's
knowledge is power but you need to do X
Y and Z in a certain order but here what
you've provided and you you're
continuing to provide is knowledge that
people can use
that real estate within their brain I'm
deliberately not giving it a name um
because it's it's distributed real
estate that allows them to take an
unpleasant feeling and work with it um
that it has more dimensionality than we
probably
realize um that's becoming clear to me
that rarely if ever is there less
dimensionality um you can always give it
more dimensionality by just shifting
your attention and you can practice this
really so you know like there's a story
that I tell about when I the brief uh
moment when I tried to learn how to
paint you know and so uh there's an
object like a cup and you have this
three-dimensional object and you want to
render it on a two-dimensional canvas so
you could just try to draw the cup and
then what you get is a pretty shitty
looking you know cup um but what what a
realist painter will teach you to do is
to take the cup and to break it apart
into pieces of light and then what you
try to paint are the pieces of light so
you're transferring your first what
you're doing is you're taking this very
low dimensional coarse object called a
cup and you're breaking it into tiny
little pieces of light which is what the
visual system does which is what the
visual system does and so what you're
doing is you're categorizing it
differently in order to emphasize the
features that are more High dimensional
that are in there right they're in there
in in the brain but you can but what
you're doing essentially is you're
you're having the brain your brain is
applying attention to basically um focus
more on those details and then you
transfer the details on to the
two-dimensional canvas and what you get
is a pretty decent looking
three-dimensional Cup on a
two-dimensional canvas aming un unless
you're me and and then it still looks
shitty uh you know and so maybe I'll
I'll take it up again sometime uh in the
future but my point is that you can do
that with your own sensory condition of
your body in Emotion you can
deliberately focus on what your heart is
doing to the to your the best of your
ability that you can sense it right or
you can deliberately Focus on your
breathing or you could deliberately
focus on what your muscles are how they
how tense they feel you can you can
change the dimensionality of your
experience by the shifting of your
attention I love it and uh forgive me
for giving another example but I think
it's one that will resonate with both of
us and hopefully with our listeners as
well which is um the great Oliver Sachs
neurologist and author um talked about
and wrote about you know he'd work with
these patients that were either had
locked in syndrome or severe autism or
severe tourettes or Parkinson's and you
know most people would even clinicians
who specialize in those areas would look
at those people and say that they're
living in a diminished world it's it's
they lack capacities that other people
have and um and it's all about the a the
absence of certain abilities and uh and
then what he did eventually was
incredible he loved animals so he would
spend time thinking about what would be
like for instance to be a bat hanging in
the corner of a room and experience the
room not through vision but mainly
through echolocation and he would spend
a lot of time thinking about that he
also did a lot of drugs at one point in
his career and then stopped because they
were very destructive drugs not just
psychedelics but also methamphetamine so
yes he has that but he eventually
changed his practice to trying to
experience human emotion but first think
about animal sensory experience MH and
and he would do that for lots of
different types of animals octopus and
bats and all these different things and
then it allowed him in his words it
allowed him to then interact with
patients in a way where he could feel
maybe even empathize a little bit with
how they experienced life and then he
would write books about it in a way and
here I'm borrowing someone else's words
that storied these people into almost
greater Larger than Life characters and
now of course he wasn't trying to
detract from their suffering but he was
trying to give people an understanding
of what that suffering was like through
their actual experience and he did it in
my opinion and the opinion of many other
people a masterful job in doing and and
it but it came through much in the same
way that your art teacher said you know
pay attention to the way the the the
changes in light across the the the
object as opposed to trying to draw draw
the object themselves that when we so
the the takeaway here that I I think
we're arriving at is that that you've
provided is that
if we take a if we add dimensionality to
our description of or experience of the
sensory inputs and there's a ton of it
to reach to and we maybe even come up
with some new internal labels or
language based labels that we can
experience the world in much richer and
much more adaptive ways absolutely and I
I love I love your stories and I love
this story in particular about Oliver
sax because um it resonates with my
experience when I was reading um Ed
yong's new book oh um first he wrote We
contain multitudes which I think one
aiter and then um uh what is the recent
one with animals an immense World an
immense world and what I what I was
thinking was you
know it's a first of all it's a
masterful masterful masterful book I I
wish I had written that book I I wrote
him a fan letter I was like this is such
an amazing book it's an amazing book um
but because he help helps
you
experience so what what I want to say is
this that there are all these animals
that have different sensory surfaces
than we do and they can detect signals
in the world that are that we that are
not relevant to us because we don't have
sensory surfaces for
them and it reminds you first of all
that what you experience as reality is
really not in the world alone and it's
not in your head alone it is in the
trans action between the two you know
your the neurons in your brain in in
your nervous system are also part of the
reality and so reality is the
transaction reality are the are the
features that are the transaction
between signals in the world and signals
in your brain
and the parts of the world that some
other animals experience that we will
never experience they're not really part
of our reality because they don't
interact with any of the anything that
we have but for those animals it's part
of their Niche it's part of their you
know Niche is just the word for the
parts of the world that matter to you
basically and I was thinking that if
people read this book and you know maybe
it will help them have empathy for other
people who don't have Minds like theirs
and who don't experience the world in
the way that they do your description of
what what um Oliver sax his what his um
his actions were and his schools it did
occur to me that this book by Edy would
be a great
tool for helping people to understand
that the way that they experience the
world it might be different than how
other people experience the world and
even a little bit of a window on that it
would be a good thing so I'd like to ask
you more about this word
affect and then I'd like to discuss how
things that we do or don't do might be
useful for putting us in Broad
categories of affect so that we might
experience particular arrays of emotions
um so this is my attempt to understand
affect in an effort to think about some
actionable items
absolutely I love the word affect the
way you described it setting up a
potential or a series of potentialities
for different emotions to occur you know
I make it a point to get sunlight in my
eye in the morning to try and wake up my
brain and body because indeed it does
that um uh broadly speaking I make an
effort to get good sleep at night
because that makes everything better
absolutely and when I'm not sleeping
well or enough it makes everything worse
this is non-clinical non- nuanced
language but I think most people when
they hear affect and if they think about
the examples I just gave kind of
understand like yeah like when a kid is
tired young kid they get cranky when
we're sleep deprived we get cranky
indeed there are times when I'm sleep
deprived and Little Things Great on me
they like a splinter just feels super
annoying and maybe even painful but when
I'm well rested things are going better
it's not that bad so tell tell us more
about affect because I think it's a
really important Anchor Point for us to
understand emotions in ourselves and
other people
neuroscientists
think
about the sensory systems for touch and
proception which we call somata
sensation as being in the service of
motor move skeletal motor movements you
really the our sense of touch and even
Vision actually also works this way um
and he and actually audition does too
these senses actually serve in um the
brain's ability to um control the
movements of the body and the same thing
is
true uh for the um regulating the
systems of the body so brains one of
their fundamental jobs are to coordinate
and um regulate the systems inside your
body your heart your lungs your gut you
know all the moving parts and the
information the the sensory signals that
that those um organs and and tissues and
so on send back to the
brain
um as I said before those sensory
signals are important to the brain's
ability to regulate the body but we
don't feel them
directly we usually experience them as
affective feelings these very simple
physical sorts of feelings and then we
elaborate them in various ways they they
really when they get very intense that
those are the moments when the brain
creates a creates a motion out of
them
so the brain's regulation of the body
the predictive regulation of the body is
the technical term is allostasis but
when I'm explaining this to the public I
use a metaphor and you know all
metaphors are wrong but some metaphors
are less wrong and useful so the
metaphor that I use is um your brain is
running a budget for your body and it's
not budgeting money it's budgeting
glucose and salt and oxygen and water
and all the nutrients that you need to
stay alive and well and so you can think
about withdrawals from that budget like
burning glucose or using up oxygen um
you can think about deposits like
sleeping and eating um you can think
about you know
savings um so when you're with a friend
who you trust and you know everything
you do actually is just slightly less
metabolically expensive right and you
can also think about taxes um like if
you are stressed socially stressed
within two hours of eating a meal that
same meal will cost
you aund the equivalent of 104 more
calories in the inefficiency that you
will metabolize it because of that
stress um meaning you'll burn more
energy you'll be more
inefficient in metabolizing the food so
it's as if you had eaten 104 more
calories oh so I had exactly backwards
and so over the course of a year that's
11 pounds so when we say that people are
taxing on us yeah we like it's literally
true their language Works their language
works so the way I describe it is that
you can think about affect as a quick
and dirty summary of the state of your
body but
budget if things are going reasonably
well then you'll feel okay you might
even feel
Pleasant if you're running a deficit in
your body budget then you're going to
feel fatigued or or
distressed and that doesn't mean
something is necessarily wrong like for
example when you exercise you get to a
certain point where you've reached your
ventilatory load usually it's like you
know 20 minutes in or 10 minutes in or
whatever depending on how hard you're
working and you start to feel unpleasant
and fatigued but that doesn't mean that
something's wrong that just means that
you're working really hard and you have
to push through it and then you know
when you you know drink water and you
know you eat afterwards and replenish
and then you're fine right in fact
you're better it's it's a a way of um
building a better stronger future
you so affect is basically you know when
when things when you're feeling really
worked up it probably means that
something's uncertain
somewhere so I just think about these as
like quick and dirty ways of thinking
about your your what your what Your
affect means and um and then oftentimes
as we've said before emotion regulation
that is controlling emotion really
actually is not so much about changing
the meaning of affect it's changing the
affect um and um so it's useful to
understand that affect is tied to the
state of your body or actually what it's
tied to is your brain's beliefs about
the state of your body your brain is
modeling the state of the body and
that's interception that's the technical
word interception is not your awareness
of your body it's your brain's modeling
of your body what your brain believes to
be true about the metabolic state of
your body and that's how I think about
affect that's how I think about my own
affect that's and my daughter actually
who um you know was depressed for so I
should say depression is like a bankrupt
body budget like you just can't move you
you feel fatigued so fatigued that you
can't move and you're very distressed
it's like bankruptcy and actually if you
I mean depression is a metabolic illness
and if you look at the symptoms of
depression they really are about
metabolic
um uh having metabolic deficits
basically and it's interesting that one
of the Hallmark features of depression
subjectively speaking is lack of
positive anticipation about the future
which makes perfect sense from the
perspective of a depleted brain body
budget yes exactly you're and you're
basically think about the fact that
prediction error right so if you're
feeling unpleasant you're not going to
be anticipating Pleasant things and even
if those things that are in the world
could give you pleasure you won't notice
them because learn learning from
prediction error things that you didn't
predict is expensive and if you don't
have the resources you're not going to
right so it's but anyways my daughter
came up with this um after we had this
very interesting thing that happened to
us on another trip um we were in Sweden
because I was giving a a keynote at The
kolinska Institute and we went I took
her to Sweden and this is when she was
recovering from depression and like you
know she is just one of the millions of
young
adults who you know adolesence young
adults who were experiencing depression
and uh we got to Sweden and she was very
very jet lagged we both were it was like
one of these like you know we had to
like you know Planes Trains and
Automobiles like it was just you know
getting there and she woke up the next
morning and
she she looked horrible she felt
horrible it actually seemed to me like
she was about to enter another
depressive episode and I said to her I
basically got her out of bed I fed her a
meal I gave her four ibuprofen and I put
her back to sleep and she got up five
hours later and she was absolutely fine
her mood was fine now I'm not telling
you that Ibuprofen is the an
anti-depressant that you should take if
you're depressed but what I'm telling
you is that you know you said something
Andrew that was so interesting at the
beginning you said am I fatigued does my
body do I have pain somewhere is my body
hurt you know these are well right when
basically what she was having was she
was fatigued and she was having what I
would call um it's called the technical
word is visceral notion which means her
stomach hurt her you know everything
hurt and sure you know her muscles
probably hurt too but it was really her
innards really she just was distressed
and the um the ibuprofen helped her get
back to sleep and then she slept and she
got up and she was completely fine and
then we walked around Stockholm for the
rest of the day talking about this
experience which for her was like
flipping on a light switch you know how
emotions are made this book that I
referred to I wrote that book for her I
wrote that book for her but also for me
because it was a way of putting down on
paper all the things that I wanted her
to know that and that I thought other
people should know about their kids you
know and maybe even their kids could
read it but what she did with that was
she came up with a New
Concept called the emotional flu and the
emotional flu is when you're having a
bad body budgeting day and you're just
like you didn't get enough sleep maybe
or you know there's some stress at at at
work or at school that you can't get rid
of otherwise you know my husband likes
to say well uh you know other people's
opinions of you are just electrical
activity in somebody's head which I love
like that's just another way of
categorizing it it's sort of like taking
apart the taking apart the cup into
pieces of light right and so whatever
there are just these moments where you
feel depleted and you could use that I
mean the we usually we often use affect
to as a as a indicator of how the world
is you know if I feel bad something must
be bad wrong in the world but you have
to resist that sometimes because
sometimes there's nothing wrong in the
world it's just that you didn't get
enough sleep or you know you need to
have a little bit more you know protein
or maybe you haven't gone for a walk and
you're stiff or whatever you need to do
some stretching are those sorry to
interrupt but I think people are going
to want to Anchor to a few of these um
you positive steps that they can take to
to I don't want to say replenish but to
shift affect in Positive Directions
sleep movement nutrition yes and I've
heard you say before that we are
essentially amino acid forging machines
so I noticed you said protein you didn't
say you need a bagel you said protein um
we could go down that rabbit hole maybe
maybe we do maybe we don't but I want to
use this also just as a quick
opportunity to say as you're saying all
this one can immediately understand why
alcohol and drugs of abuse are both so
compelling yeah right you're not feeling
well so take a you're feeling tired take
a stimulant that releases dopamine and
epinephrine but you're taxing your
already taxed body budget yes in a way
that then puts you in a more depleted
State later or alcohol like you feel
lousy alcohol never did this for me but
friends I have who are recovered
alcoholics will tell me that it was like
a magic Elixir it made them feel right
that's their language but then of course
there's a price to pay later because
then it drops your Baseline below where
it was initially absolutely
100% but I just also want to say that so
is serotonin like so are so is so are
ssris
maybe and when I say maybe what I mean
by that is if you you really have a
metabolic problem like say something's
wrong with your mitochondria or you're
recovering from an illness and you know
that or or there's just some metabolic
problem in your
body that metabolic problem is
real if you start to feel unpleasant you
will I mean feel unpleasant it will feel
your mood will be
negative if you start taking serot if
you start taking ssris which will leave
more serotonin in the synapses your uh
neurons before it's re it's taken up
again that will juice the system you
will be able to spend you'll be able to
move you'll feel like you have more
energy for a while but your nervous
system is is a complex system and so
it's going to make adjustments
elsewhere to try to deal with that
budgeting problem so exactly what
happens when you take drugs of abuse and
what happens on the short term can
happen for some people with ssris on the
longer term where at first it starts to
work and then it stops stops working and
you start to gain weight and you know
and your because your metabolism is
slowing because your brain is attempting
to deal with that with that budgeting
problem so it really matters what the
you know what the source is it could be
that your brain believes you have a
budgeting problem but there really isn't
one it could be that there really is one
these things matter to how you treat it
one thing uh to um just mentioned about
ssris and I unfortunately for reasons of
confidentiality I can't cite The Source
on this but let me just say that
somebody who's highly informed in the in
the landscape of of pharmaceutical
treatments for um psychiatric challenges
has told me that there's an emerging
Theory among psychiatrists is kind of a
collective emerging theory that um one
of the reasons why nowadays you hear
about so-called treatment resistant
depression but you did not hear about
so-called treatment resistant depression
prior to the Advent of ssris is that
there's a growing body of thought in the
psychiatric community that SSR eyes may
over time as you're pointing out deplete
the very neural systems that subserve
enhanced mood so it's it's different
than a drug of abuse that gives you a
very acute effect like methamphetamine
or cocaine or alcohol but that over time
you may actually be pulling the very
neural circuits and neurochemicals that
would allow for positive affect deeper
and deeper into the trenches um so to
speak and so there's a growing number of
people who simply don't respond to the
drugs any longer or other treatments
right so I wasn't trying to say the
mechanism is the same I was basically
saying the theme is the same and I'm
agreeing with you what happens over the
short term with drugs of abuse happens
over the longer term with for some
people with ssris because it hasn't been
recognized yet that the that at the
basis depression is a metabolic problem
and when you have a metabolic problem
like diabetes or obesity or like uh or
um heart disease it's not that that
causes depression it's that there's a
common problem which is that somewhere
in this very complex system of your
metabolism there's there there's a drag
and it produces negative mood and that's
how you experience it sometimes it's
good not to turn it's productive not to
turn uh that negative affect into to an
emotion sometimes you know sometimes a
cigar is just a cigar sometimes you just
need to deal with the affec of Problem
by dealing with the physical your
physical state and that's the tricky bit
is knowing when is affect telling you
something is wrong with the world and
when is it telling you that there's
something wrong with your physical state
that you need to attend to I think
everything to me at least starts with a
good night's sleep on a consistent basis
and and every psychiatric Challenge and
indeed suicide itself um is seems to be
associated with and often preceded by
challenges in sleeping changes in in in
circadian rhythm so I think um that's
why to me sleep is the foundation of
mental health and physical health yep
absolutely and so when I tell people
when they say well what can I do I was
like well if there's only if there's
only one thing that you could pick I
would say get get a good night's sleep
on a regular basis if you could pick two
more I would say eat healthfully like
stop eating pseudo food don't get me
wrong like I love french fries I love
french fries they're like that's like
God's most perfect food I mean really
but eat healthfully like eat real food
and get exercise and if you do those
three things I know I sound like a
mother and so feel free to roll your
eyes at me but as a neuroscientist those
are the actually before you start with
all the you know mentalizing Jedi tricks
you could just start with this and that
would actually take you pretty far and
and um and that will resonate very well
with our audience um the basics of sleep
exercise food sunlight and social
connection are the ones that we just
anchor those five are the ones that that
we just keep returning to over and over
again and I think people will say oh
it's just simple uh motherly advice but
I would I think that those five things
even just the one thing around sleep
there's some work that's required to get
that done so it's not as simple the
categories are simple but the work
that's required to get great sleep as
often as one can on a consistent basis
if you're raising kids have a career
live in the world um there's a lot there
and so that's where I think there's
there's a there's an elaboration of of
things and one needs to learn to be be
flexible like when you're traveling how
do you do that when you know friends are
visiting how do you do that when
weather's off and so on the the
relationship piece is something I was
just going to I was just going to say
I'm so glad you mentioned that I'm so
glad you mentioned that because You'
said before and and this was another one
of those moments I listen to you I've
listened to as many of your podcasts as
I possibly can but I think it was the
first or the second one with Lex fredman
um where you said you know we are
regulating each other's nervous systems
I will never forget that and you
know I imagine that you married your
husband for a number of different
reasons but um when people pair up with
romantic partners with friends with
co-workers the ideal situation is one in
which we are not tacked
where maybe even people and just being
around them or just knowing that they
are in our lives provides a sort of
deposit to yeah it's a savings it
provides a saing for sure and and I
think that's a lot of what emotional
resonance to put kind of Pop language on
it is is all about who who feels good to
be around who doesn't feel good to be
around I would say the best thing for a
human nervous system is another human
and the worst thing for a human nervous
system
is also another human and so you really
want to be around the people who make
you the best the best version of
yourself that you could be and that
doesn't mean that you always get a
savings like sometimes you're sometimes
you're taking care of that person and so
you're you're absorbing some of the
their burden right and vice versa but I
would
say the research on you know social
isolation and loneliness and so on shows
us that that you know well along with
research on synchrony and there's just a
whole bunch of research to to suggest
that um we are the caretakers of each
other's nervous systems and it doesn't
matter what your opinion is like it
doesn't you know it just but we just
that's how we evolved as a species and
so you get to
decide what kind of a person are you
going to be you know are you going to be
uh are you going to be a savings or are
you going to be a tax and in general it
seems that people who decide that
they're going to be a savings
um tend to because people gravitate
towards that and want more of that yeah
and hopefully would provide that also I
mean I think the reciprocity piece here
feels really really strong well that's a
really interesting thing about um about
the synchrony work right so there's work
that if you research that if you put
people together who don't even know each
other but if they if they like each
other and they they have a sense of
trust even after a couple of minutes
they start to synchronize their physical
signals their heart rate starts to
synchronize their movements start to syn
their heart rate probably synchronizes
because their breathing starts to
synchronize right and it's really
interesting to see what you what you
typically see is that who is pacing and
who is leading like one person is the
leader and then the other person is the
Pacer um and I got that language from
when I learned hypnosis by the way and
um but it switches back and forth like
who's the leader like in a in a good in
a in a what would we say good like in a
in an interaction that looks productive
it it's switching all the time who is
who who is pacing and who is leading
it's not that always one person is is um
is in charge so to speak physiologically
speaking we did a series recently on
Mental Health with Paul kti who's a um
psychiatrist and the word narcissism
came up a few times because people have
a lot of questions about that you know
and he um emphasized that narcissists
are not confident they they operate from
a place of of a deficit of pleasure It's
never enough and an intense Envy
although that's not how they present and
they're often usually not aware of it
themselves but it's what leads healthy
people to feel as if the interactions
with those people narcissists often can
be very compelling in the moment but
they feel very taxed afterwards and kind
of confused by what happened and it
sounds like it uh ties back to this lack
of synchrony um on the positive side of
things um it's also clear from what you
just said that when people regulate each
other's nervous systems in a way where
people are making little deposits and
providing savings for each other or
maybe things are just neutral that um
those nervous systems are then in a
position to like pay attention to other
things too and and and not just try and
work out the Dynamics oh for sure oh and
that's very true at work so there's
research showing that um especially in
the creativity you know sector
Innovation sector of the economy the
best predictor of performance on the job
is the extent to which people feel I
mean after you account for sleep and and
you know watering and sleeping and
feeding right like the that um the best
predictor is the amount of trust that
you have in your team and in your
managers because if the world is
predictable it could still be things
could be hard even when things are
unpredictable you have people you know
who have your back and so basically what
you're doing is you're you're um they're
making you know deposits or savings
they're causing Savings in each other's
body budgets so their their resources
can be spent on the harder things which
is you know failing and you know call
having to pick yourself back up and try
again which is you know partly what you
do when you're an innovator so I think
that there's also research to show that
in your personal life when you do random
acts of kindness for people or when
you're kind in general you derive also a
body budgeting benefit from that um you
know so for a while had a friend who um
we would meet each other for lunch once
a month and you know we would take turns
paying I mean we could both pay for
ourselves but we kind of got a double
hit you know he paid for me one month
and then I would pay for him one month
and then you know so we get the double
hit of uh you know being kind to someone
else and uh you know and also they got
the you know benefit of someone being
kind to them and I'll just say I think
kindness is a I don't know that we have
so many conversations about that in our
culture right now but I think kindness
is very very underrated and should be
you know like when I'm when my when I
feel like
I bake bread for my
neighbor who's in his 70s him and his
wife that's what I do when I you know
when I'm not feeling good and you know
if I I mean after I've taken care of the
physical the possible uh physical cause
is I and then I feel great because he's
always
so he's always so grateful and and then
I felt like I made his day better and
then also he helps me in other ways like
with my garden and stuff because he's
just like a Master Gardener and so I
feel like we have this relationship
where we help each other and I know it
sounds really sappy
but and even though all the research
backs up what I'm saying I it doesn't
quite describe the feeling of when
someone is just really happy because you
just gave them a little surprise and
they're you know like that's that's
there's just some juice in that I
think in some culture out there there's
a word for that and someone will tell us
I'm sure there is I'm sure there is well
I have to say um I've thoroughly enjoyed
this conversation oh me too I I've been
looking forward to it for a long time
and you've provided us with a really
Broad
Arc but also a deep dive into not just
how emotions are made not just about
affect but as you mentioned earlier you
know really how the nervous system works
and I I'm certain in fact that our
audience is taking this in and realizing
that that knowledge is incredibly
powerful the the addition of nuance both
to language and to sort of
self-reflection States um as extremely
valuable often times when one gets into
into a conversation that has some level
of reductionism and you get into gnomen
clature and things like that it can
really pull away from the the real life
experience of something but this is
exactly the opposite what you've done
for us today is you've provided such a
rich array of information that adds
richness and depth to the real life
experience and um and that is really
invaluable so on behalf of myself and
all the listeners and the people
watching this I want to say thank you
for for today's discussion thank you for
the books you've written which we've
provided links to in the show note
captions thanks for showing up on social
media despite the um the the the
challenges that exist there sometimes
you always handle yourself uh so well
there and we'll refer people to your uh
excellent social media accounts as well
and and just for all the work that
you're doing and that your laboratory
and you're now director of various
things and related to Ai and more and
we'll talk about this hopefully in
future episodes but uh just a really
enormous thank you thank you thank you
for joining me for today's discussion
about the Psychology and Neuroscience of
emotions with Dr Lisa Feldman Barrett if
you're learning from and or enjoying
this podcast please subscribe to our
YouTube channel that's a terrific zero
cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on both
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a
five-star review please check out the
sponsors mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode that's the
best way to support this podcast if you
have questions or comments about the
podcast or topics or guests that you'd
like me to consider for the hubman Lab
podcast please put those in the comment
section on YouTube I do read all the
comments not on today's episode but on
many previous episodes of The hubman Lab
podcast we discuss supplements while
supplements aren't necessary for
everybody many people derive tremendous
benefit from them for things like
improving sleep for hormone support and
for Focus if you'd like to see the
supplements discussed on the hubman Lab
podcast you can go to live momentus
spelled o us so Liv mous.com
huberman if you're not already following
me on social media I am huberman lab on
all platforms so that's Instagram
Twitter now called x Facebook LinkedIn
and threads and at all those places I
discuss science and science related
tools some of which overlap with the
content of the huberman Lab podcast but
much of which is distinct from the
content covered on the hubman Lab
podcast so again it's hubman lab on all
social media platforms and if you
haven't already subscribed to our zeroc
cost neural network newsletter the
neural network newsletter is a monthly
newsletter that includes podcast
summaries as well as toolkits in the
form of protocols so these are short
PDFs that list out the specific things
that one could do in order to for
example improve sleep improve learning
regulate dopamine we have toolkits and
protocols that relate to Fitness from
our fitness episodes and much much more
to sign up simply go to hubman lab.com
click on the newsletter tab at the top
of the site and then enter your email
and click subscribe I want to point out
that we do not share your email with
anybody and again the newsletter is
completely zero cost thank you once
again for joining me for today's
discussion with Dr Lisa Feldman Barrett
and last but certainly not least thank
you for your interest in
science